austria
austria
there are hiring covet inspectors to
hunt down the unvaccinated because there
is a new law saying everyone has to be
vaccinated and there is a massive fine
if you don't get vaccinated we're seeing
an expansion of the vaccine mandates in
boston we're now seeing it in chicago i
think chicago is doing mask mandates
they're going to be implementing a
vaccine mandate soon and uh i'll take
credit for this one because you know why
you know why i i'll take credit for the
prediction that's what i meant not the
lockdowns that's what i meant no no see
i get things wrong and when i do boy do
people like to bring it up so if i ever
get the opportunity to be like ah i
called that one so i said a little while
ago i think hard lockdowns are coming
and this seems like the natural
evolution of it first they lock
everybody down everyone says this sucks
then they say okay now we're gonna lock
it all down unless everyone does as
they're told then gets the vaccine and
that's what we're seeing so we're
getting it we're watching what's
happening in europe much like we did
last year at the start of the pandemic
and i i believe we'll start seeing much
of that happen here in the u.s the
difference you got places like texas
florida south dakota these red states
they're not going to be playing that
game
however one of the problems with the
democrats narrative on kovitt is that
omicron seems to be relatively mild so
now joe biden has announced he's going
to make sure everybody gets at-home
tests and they're going to be sending
out tests you know 500 million or
whatever and i'm like
that's interesting because axios put out
a story where they said americans don't
care about omicron anymore about covet
there's this uh video of shep smith
being like i don't care i don't want to
talk about this
how can you reignite the fear
send everybody tests maximize the news
around exploding cases and then terrify
everybody again i mean that is to say if
people have coveted they should be
taking care of it but what we need to
get away from is that fear
so let's talk about what's going on we
got jesse waters gave a speech at the
turning point usa event and uh fauci is
demanding he be fired because he used
explosive rhetoric and the story i wish
we could have been leading with but it's
just not it's not enough and it's a
little too tribalist nancy pelosi was uh
presenting the build back better bill
and someone yelled let's go brandon i
just i just love the civil disobedience
you know people yelling and stuff so
we're gonna talk about all that stuff
and my friends
it's holidays ian is gone but we're
hanging out with chris carr
yes sir how's it going to be here who
are you i'm the executive editor at
timcast.com that's right yeah happy to
be here so basically
you know it's a holiday so we're keeping
it in the family everybody you know from
the channel is going to be coming i
don't i don't know who we're having who
are having tomorrow to be completely
honest because let's be real
getting people to fly out
i'm trying the week like just before
christmas christmas christmas eve is
friday it's impossible but jack murphy
is coming tomorrow and a lot of people
were asking in the chat they were like
why isn't jack here why isn't jack here
and i'm like because jet comes on
wednesdays he comes every other
wednesday doesn't come on tuesdays but
he will be here and we're going to hang
out with him and we're going to talk and
there's a lot to talk about of course
but uh yeah man how's it going how's it
going merry christmas i'm chilling yeah
merry christmas to you too
cool we had a great party the other
night that's right we had a big party we
launched and we launched a book tales
from the inverted world at
invertedworldbook.com and you were the
editor yes sir it's an awesome book yeah
yeah like i autographed and everything
it was it was awesome yeah we're gonna i
guess we're gonna have the whole team
autograph the book and then we'll like
auction it off or something just help
support the you know making more of it
we got luke here though yeah
i i think i might have heard about the
website that you work for just a little
bit oh yeah yeah do we have a reputation
all right but anyway lots of crazy news
to get into especially surrounding dr
fauci and that's why i decided to
present him in his uh happiest form
living his best life of course declaring
himself the science and zapping innocent
puppies and small monkeys which is
perfectly depicted on this t-shirt which
you can exclusively get on
thebestpoliticalshirts.com the best
political shorts.com and then you could
send this message out to the general
public uh which is a needed message and
it's a very important message because
it's a true message uh that that people
need to understand the ramifications i
just want to say how how insane it is
that you actually got someone to make a
graphic of pouchiest emperor palpatine
using forced lightning on monkeys and
puppies while yelling i am science i
apologize i couldn't fit the orphanage
children in there oh we tried but we did
try look up the the experiments i am
science
nice so yeah thanks for having me guys
it's a pleasure well this is definitely
luke's finest shirt i'm a little bit
intimidated by the idea of chicago and
boston going into these kind of weird
fits just as i'm about to visit boston
for the first time over christmas so
that's going to be
interesting but i hope it all works out
hopefully i can just kind of slide under
the radar i guess we'll have to see what
happens anyway yes ladies and gentlemen
we have an awesome sponsor tonight we
have three in one flashlight.com that's
the number three in and the number one
flashlight.com we got sent the sample
it's really cool guess what it's a
flashlight you can turn it on i don't
want to point too much of the screen but
here's the crazy thing you pull down on
the front and it pops out and there's a
bunch of different attachments
so you can do that's really cool i got
sent this and i was just like actually
the one i think i like the most is this
because we have like the 3d printer and
we're trying to do engineering stuff so
this like bendy flashlight thing is
actually pretty important thing yeah but
then the other thing that's cool is the
uh this one right here like the regular
flashlight attachment can be focused
if you uh if you if you you pull on it
you can focus and expand it that's
really cool so this is three in one
flashlight.com man i love these these
guys over at prepper's peak because it's
like the easiest sponsor spot to read
it's a flashlight you want a flashlight
with multiple attachments go to three
and one flashlight dot com you get 66
off use the promo code timkas20 for an
additional 20 off and um seriously
grateful to everybody who's willing to
sponsor the show especially when we get
new sponsors that's got functional
equipment that we think is really cool
want to use so again 3in1flashlight.com
don't forget go to timcast.com become a
member help support our work we have a
members-only segment coming up around 11
or so p.m and you can also go to
invertedworldbook.com to pick up our
first book
i don't know
so let me just add to this we're being
we're currently being re evaluated by
newsguard it says this website is in the
process of being rated or reviewed i'm
really curious as to what they say about
us because we have like this political
news but we also have pop culture crisis
which is like what's let me go to the
homage what do we have on here it's like
infamous island boys tick tock tick
tockers mocked by ufc audience we've got
in the long island monster inverted
world podcast you know it's it's like
some of it is just cultural stuff some
the vlog i i really i'm interested to
see what they write about this they're
gonna be like a far-right website that
hosts a vlog about skating and chickens
and also makes content about keanu
reeves in the matrix and spider-man and
it'll be interesting to see but all
that's possible thanks to you guys
supporting our work and if you want to
get our latest book go to
invertedworldbook.com
it is a collection of stories about
close contact with ghosts ufos serial
killers and discussions on simulation
theory it's the first of many and this
one is just a variety of stories but the
next one that's coming out i'm really
excited for series volume 2 is currently
in the walks works we think it's about
six months out and that's going to be
the ghosts of the civil war and there's
this is crazy stuff so the stories we're
already hearing about the conspiracies
and i'm not talking about crazy like
government experience i'm talking about
like people hiding money and like
mafioso stuff it's gonna be a blast
anyway
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel let's talk about this first
story we got this from blick.ch
due to compulsory vaccination from
february austria is looking for people
to control those who refuse to be
vaccinated anyone who does not want to
be vaccinated in austria from february
2022 must expect a fine employees should
ensure the fines are paid that is why uh
that is why we are now looking for
inspectors
i must stress we used google translate
so some of these words may not get the
full and correct meaning across but uh
my understanding is look at this the
vaccination inspectors receive a wage of
at least 2 744 euros
or about 2880 francs
they say uh
lens now wants to engage people who are
supposed to control vaccine vaccination
refusals as reported today they should
check whether those who do not get
vaccinated are really paying for it
translation error because whoever does
not get vaccinated will be asked to pay
up to 3600 euro the equivalent of a good
3740 francs
well history repeats itself i suppose
some people call them inspectors i think
hunters is is a better uh more
appropriate term here statist hunters
going after you know individuals who
believe in bodily autonomy now this is
again according to a lot of local news
reports coming out of austria they're
talking about how they're going to be
paying people nearly 40 000 a year to do
this job how the fines could range a
couple thousand dollars of course a
couple thousand euros but uh
this again goes along with the decree
that they're going to be pushing forward
in february that pretty much outlaws
individuals
who are not vaccinated which is
absolutely crazy germany has talked
about imposing similar measures
themselves their health minister
recently said that they want to
implement mandatory vaccinations on
everyone austria's doing it how this
policy will be implemented it's going to
be nasty it's going to be disgusting
because people are going to be called up
people are going to be investigated
people are going to be spied on tracked
traced and databased and said hey did
you take the shot and they're going to
have to say no and then the government's
going to come with jack boot thugs and
say you're going to give us money or
you're going to go to jail it's going to
happen which is crazy but regardless of
how the policy actually gets activated
what are the people going to do the
people are still unvaccinated in austria
are they going to acquiesce by the by in
large numbers or are they going to fight
back what do you think's going to happen
over there i think what would you do
i'm i'm not going to do that i'm not
going to be forced to do anything i'm
not going to be forced to say something
i don't want to say or do something i
want to do
period yeah like that's just my
personality i agree yeah so uh
the local reports that we're also
hearing about is that they will be
working with employers and saying that
they will be denying them paychecks or
taking their paychecks away from them um
and pressuring them to do this uh that
way so uh i mean obviously i wouldn't
what if they can't get the vaccine you
know
what if they can't get it for medical or
religious reasons um
if you've received like let's say you're
an older person you've received
monoclonal antibodies you can't get it
for 90 days so like what do they do it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter which
reason is yeah so so here's what i'll
add to this right what we saw last year
is europe started doing these lockdowns
then the us started picking them up
we started seeing europe locking down
again now we've got all these major
cities in the u.s doing it boston's
doing it chicago's announcing it and i'm
i'm actually headed back to chicago i'm
like oh man i don't even know if i want
to go oh boy yeah because they have mask
mandates and now they're saying they
want a vaccine maybe for all restaurants
and i'm like i'm supposed to go there
for the holidays
why would i why would i want to go give
money to a place like that or be
involved in a place like that out in
west virginia none of that people walk
around doing whatever they want not not
only do you not have to wear a mask you
can carry a gun oh yeah illinois is the
opposite of that you go to jail and
you'll get fined and uh it's very so
they're saying now i think
they're gonna implement a vaccine
mandate for indoor dining and like some
restaurant association in chicago is
saying wait until after the holidays
because we want to make money so here's
what i think
we're seeing this in austria we're
seeing it in germany we're seeing it
escalate and they're ahead of us i think
it's very likely we will get to this
point in the united states very soon
well one thing that i've been kind of
making the point about is that a lot of
these restrictions a lot of these
mandates all kind of come in steps and
we're seeing the steps followed almost
identically but under different names
all around the world so obviously
austria uh
kind of is leading the pack here but
what what is happening in austria is
going to be happening with the rest of
the world we saw australia kind of leave
the world with their insanity the other
other places are going to be following
suit with very similar policies as well
we just saw boston implement their quote
be together initiative which is
absolutely draconian orwellian and
insane it's like calling you know the
patriot act patriotic but it absolutely
was it it does the exact opposite of
that doesn't it just feel good
to be a a a a a face in the crowd of
people with pitchforks and torches
mindlessly marching along and demanding
everyone else capitulate and and you
know march alongside the state doesn't
it just feel good right come on everyone
wants to do that you're basically saying
suffer as i suffer yeah yeah join the
club if i have to deal with this so do
you if i have to take a risk
you do as well which is absolutely crazy
that's exactly right absolutely insane
and and again they're they're quote be
together initiative is literally
requiring vaccine passports for indoor
activities which is predominantly going
to be discriminating against black
people in this country
i'm with shep smith
i don't care i don't want to talk about
it anymore
that what was that what was that he said
he said maybe i'm just better getting on
omacron
on the cross
for biden's sake we'll call it omnicron
that way yeah it's like uh i was told
this when i was in um
uh was it catalonia in in in like
barcelona they said that they have the
the catalan lisp
where like in spanish instead of saying
cerveza they say fedora bartholomew
barcelona and they said so it was funny
because i was in spain
there was a guy you know i'm talking to
these guys and i said um you know i've
never been to barcelona and he goes
barcelona and i went oh it's barthelon
and he was yes and another guy was like
no no it's barcelona and i was like
which one is it well apparently
apparently here's the legend there was a
king or something who had a lisp so
everyone wanted to be high status so
they started speaking with a lisp
because it was you know
prestigious so that's why we call it
omnicron because we you know because
biden is the is the is the is the
epitome of prestige yes uh
he's literally thinking that it might
just be better off for him he's triple
faxed he said to just get omnicron he's
like just give it to me so i can move on
with my life i don't want to see it
reported coming from a you know
corporate press broadcaster he doesn't
want to see it reported he's just he's
he's at his wit's end just like jim
cramer he had a similar rant
anti-vaxxers yeah that's the only
explanation yeah of course yeah well a
lot of people are having fatigue just
hearing about this non-stop and non-stop
and that's because the government has
been kind of beating this thing over the
head exploiting it to the fullest extent
trying to squeeze the limit to the last
drop and people are like we get it we
got it and again how much
sensationalistic fear-mongering nonsense
can you throw at them before they're
like we don't care they don't give a
damn that's so funny you say annie
baxter's because it reminds me of this
old uh saying in the theater if you
scratch an actor you you'll see an
actress you scratch if you scratch a
boxer you'll see an antidote what does
that mean what does it mean it's
basically just like if you bring any
kind of uh like you know actors are
supposedly very sensitive you think of
somebody like ian very sensitive guy you
scratch them they'll turn into an
actress so if you if you scratch or
confuse or harm a vaxxer somebody that's
triple vaxxed and they think they think
they're really safe then you're going to
see somebody you're going to see the
anti-vaxxer just explode i'm just saying
this i'm saying
you know if the vaccine works
and they all say it does
then these people are lying and they get
the vaccine oh that's what i'm saying
like
and and it's funny too because i think
we mentioned this yesterday how many how
many times did viral videos go around
where they're like look nancy pelosi is
not really getting vaccinated or
whatever yeah everybody was accusing
these people of not really getting the
vaccine and many of these people were
saying they weren't going to get it on
twitter because they were like trump's
vaccine i won't do it now all of a
sudden they're getting sick i'm like
just call them anti-vexers period
because they clearly lied about getting
maximum now i don't know if they
actually did or not i know efficacy
wayne's supposed to get boosters and all
that stuff but i got no problem just
saying these people are you know i'm
gonna i'm gonna operate under the
assumption that they just lied about
getting vaccinated well the other
explanation to this is that there's a
conspiracy and uh
yeah there's that i don't think they
should uh i think i think you know what
i think i think there's like a million
micro conspiracies you know what i mean
yeah i i think you know the the we're
going to find out the truth in a couple
years from now and i think we're going
to be shocked about what really was
going on today oh that this is how it
always happens with history i think how
how long did they say the gulf of tonkin
was a conspiracy theory the gulf of
tonkin incident the conspiracy theory
being that that america basically staged
the attack so we could you know enter
vietnam and i remember hearing about how
it was a conspiracy theory up until even
like only a few years ago and they were
like oh yeah actually the us did stage
that so there's there's tons of stuff
throughout history
that is purposely obfuscated and then
later on you find out what really
happened you're like wow
so how much longer until we actually get
the unredacted documents from the
assassination you know well the fda is
waiting 75 years to release the clinical
studies about the pfizer vaccine i heard
they walked it back to 55 years because
they were feeling more confident in
their product either way
they have the data and you know they say
they need you know decades to procure it
even though it's already procured and
ready to go but uh you know for our big
our well-being and understanding they
don't need any liability and they don't
need to present it until 55 years from
now which is i bet a lot of ufo stories
was just us military drone research
how hard would it be for the military to
create a quadcopter you know in the 70s
or 80s they could probably do it and
that explains why people were saying
they saw discs zipping back and forth
and moving really crazy because if you
ever watched like pro high powered
drones these things go nuts the way they
can move so rapidly and the german
military during world war ii was also
working on saucer like flying
devices as well so there's even photos
of some that look eerily similar to what
some people call of course ufos so
there's a lot of probabilities there's a
lot of things that of course we don't
know about because the government is
being extremely secretive they're hiding
a lot of data they're hiding a lot of
important information from the general
public as they're telling you trust us
give us give us your freedom give us
your economic opportunities give us your
life but we're not going to show you
anything on your end and that's
disgusting you know be really funny
there are two different scenarios that i
find would be really funny one is that
everything the government says is
completely true
like
it really was a weird-shaped cloud that
descended you know hovered spun in a
circle and then
darted off it really was a cloud believe
us why won't you believe this or it's
just like it's so far beyond what anyone
actually thinks it is and what's really
happening in the government and like
with aliens is just it's like not aliens
it's just something completely
ridiculous that no one would ever
like theorize about but i actually i
actually think like the funniest
scenario is the government's telling the
truth because that implies honesty among
the government and a lack of any like
intent for like military technology to
be you know
and that they're competent that's
another idea
that scenario got the biggest laugh in
the room yeah they're actually telling
the truth
they're like so absurd to consider yeah
the ufo everyone saw was actually a
weather phenomenon and then everyone's
like that's a lie and this poor guy is
like sitting in his office he's crying
it's like actually is a weather
phenomenon who made that famous joke
being like you don't believe in any
conspiracies you think the government is
always honest that they're batting a
thousand like they think they're always
right like are you crazy like
there's no way logically you could even
think that they're always honest they're
always you know and it's just i mean you
must be crazy if you really think that
but left a lot of lefties do think that
now which is so crazy compared to like
the 60s version of the lefty which was
anti-establishment question everything
don't trust the government don't trust
the letter a free speech no matter how
many years ago 10 years ago yeah that's
true occupy wall street was like obama
and biden are liars yeah don't trust the
big banks don't trust big pharma luke
the the the dnc in the rnc for the 2016
cycle
where was the bigger protest
um
at the democrats was the democrats it
was like over a thousand people and they
were trying to jump the fence and they
were shaking the fence the rnc had
almost nobody well the bernie bros were
pretty pissed off that they were getting
railroaded by clinton isn't this
the perfect way to understand like the
space we're in you know so there was
this guy who did a review of youtube
channels he was like tracking who was
influencing who and then he called my
channel at the time not tim castaire
ruxin didn't exist he said exclusively
critical of left
and he said the same thing about dave
rubin and a few other people and i said
isn't it possible that we're just
centrists criticizing the more extreme
and so he changed it some people to like
center and he got rid of the category
but here's here's a really good example
of where we are in the 2016 dnc rnc
cycle nobody protested republicans there
was a small handful kind of
thousands of people descended on the dnc
and tried breaking down the barricades
and hopping in and getting into the dnc
that's like
there you go
people don't like the democratic party
people didn't care a whole lot about
trump for the most part now i guess they
kind of went nuts in the last cycle
though you know
well this is why everyone thinks it's so
crazy that biden won as many votes as he
did which i do think that you're right
with that trump was anti-elected but to
look around and be like all the people
on the streets in new york city saying
stuff like you know screw joe biden is
very telling those are just normal
people walking by a news reporter and
they're like man i think i think a lot
of people are having a rude wake-up call
i wonder how many people are going
through cognitive dissonance where it's
like they weren't politically active
right they voted for joe biden and now
everything the trump supporters said
would happen is happening and they have
to reconcile that some people don't want
to do it but a lot of moderate people
are like yo
i will take a ham sandwich over joe
biden at this point
which brings me to joe biden we have the
story here oh snap the daily mail biden
says vaccinated americans can celebrate
christmas safely denies he has failed on
home testing praises trump for getting
his booster and blames unvaccinated for
omnicron surge coughs his way through
covet speech apparently uh joe biden
what's he going to do he's going to get
5 million tests to american homes amid a
nationwide shortage with lines forming a
testing center i just want to tell you
this one of the issues we had
when we had coveted here is that we had
a we had like four i think it was four
people tested negative and so we were
just like okay
four people testing it's not coveted and
then it was covered so you know you got
to make sure um whatever that means
there could be false positives and false
negatives but here's what i think is
really important about this you know joe
biden went on to say that unvaccinated
no immunity omnicron and you know he
said
death and winter and all this stuff
here's a story from axios
americans tune out omicron news despite
ominous threat ominous interest in covet
19 news versus cases over time so
omnicron is spiking and the news is
diminishing because no one cares shep
smith had his breaking point i had my
breaking point a couple days ago you
know like last week i'm like hey luke
what's the big news and luke is like we
got a bunch of vaccine we got a bunch of
cove and i'm like dude no no i don't
care anymore
yo people get it
i don't
look a bunch of people are taking this
week off like a bunch of shows are off
the air for the christmas and i'm like
no no come on you can't take off the
whole week because christmas eve is
friday
but we're only going to be doing a show
we're doing a show tomorrow and thursday
and friday we're off because nobody is
working nobody wants to talk about
what's going on nobody wants to be
dealing with this so here's what i think
how do you get the news back joe biden
needs fear the democrats need fear the
republicans are going to sweep and they
say you know red wave
so joe biden sends out half a half a
billion tests
everybody takes these tests and then
we're gonna get a big surge in reported
cases and they're gonna be like oh look
look how bad it is now truth be told
that would mean things are bad but if
without these tests people were having
mild symptoms and didn't really care
we'd get over it we'd get through it and
we'd carry on like chef smith was saying
just get it over with and just get on
with your life yeah but the problem is
that there are some people sorry luke to
join no no go ahead some people
they get the positive test and they rush
to the emergency room i've heard this
story over and over again and not just
like old people or people that are in uh
high-risk categories people that are
young relatively healthy they get the
positive test and they rush the whole
family to the emergency room they're
just like we've got covid you know you
got beds like there are people that
really do believe
perhaps thanks to the corporate press
for the most part that their life is at
risk and they have to get in a hospital
immediately it's psychosomatic and
anxiety is also one of the contributing
factors um how harsh you're going to
have to deal with covet it was obesity
and and very oddly anxiety so there's an
element to this that of course we still
don't fully understand but i kind of
agree with tim's sentiment we are tired
of it we're exhausted of it a lot of
people just don't want to hear about it
biden was coughing through this thing of
course he was also a close contact but
but during his speech he admitted that
his mandates were unpopular which is big
but say everyone gets tested now or you
know other conspiracies are going to be
that there's going to be potentially
something in these tests whatever it may
be there's a lot of theories out there
but if people do get tested and the
tests all get out there um
people are going to freak out and be
like maybe we do need this mandate which
of course is unpopular now uh but but
again the government can't even test
right they had over they had close to
two years now they can't even get the
testing right as people are waiting
eight hours in line in the freezing cold
in new york city just to get tested they
can't figure that out by now
and they look like lion i made the
comment like that looks exactly like the
dmv
because it is they're the same things
pretty much i'm worried about joe biden
man yeah because you've got elizabeth
warren cory booker jim cramer who else
they're all like i'm triple x and i got
it and what if joe biden gets it man
he's almost 80 years old yeah like he's
in the highest risk factor for something
like this
so you know that's that's kind and he's
coughing in this thing i'm like dude i i
i don't like biden but come on you know
i'm curious to know what kind of health
uh
shape his clones are in though
because i was gonna say that and i don't
want to get a good [ __ ]
that's actually see that's that's a
that's a misconception actually oh
they're not clones they're androids oh i
see right right so i say shape shifters
shape-shifting skin i think it's a
little bit more accurate
but but there's another thing that's
really i think we have to clarify for
youtube we were joking because there's
like there's someone like youtube like
what are you talking about i'm gonna
press
i spend too much time on tick tock
that's all i'll say
there's a meme that i tweeted today and
it's all the people partying and there's
a guy in the corner with a dr fouchy
sweater and it says they don't know
they're they're looking at a winter of
severe illness and death in his house
and he's like crying and he has the
gloves on and he has a needle in his arm
and i was like
just thinking about it i'm like that's
bill gates that's literally like the
statement that bill gates just released
recently saying that this is the worst
surge that we have seen so far that he's
going to be spending christmas alone and
he canceled christmas with his friends
which his voice you gotta do but you
gotta do it bill gates voice this is the
worst
sir we have ever had
so far we're entering the worst pandemic
my friend jeffrey epstein
cannot attend her christmas i can't
believe this is happening that could
also be queen elizabeth just hearing it
fairly and and she also said that she's
gonna have to spend her christmas alone
lizard people have the same voice in my
opinion yeah
yeah but if you're doing a lizard person
voice you have to like hiss yeah you
know like like you got to be like
voldemort what is this okay so bill
gates has this huge thread where is it
is it this
just when we thought things would get
back to normal he turned off the
comments so you can't even leave a
restaurant
no he's strong just when it seemed like
life would return to normal we could be
entering the worst part of the pandemic
omicron will hit home for all of us
close friends of mine like jeffrey
epstein
he didn't say that
and i've canceled most of my holiday
plans
this is his first divorce
just add in every statement he makes it
should be a meme every time he tweets
something you add somehow him mentioning
jeffrey with jeffrey epstein yeah
but yeah yeah the big unknown is how
sick omicron makes you when you take it
seriously until we know more about it
even if it's only half as severe as
delta it will be the worst surge we have
seen so far because it's so infectious
ask my friend jeffrey epstein meantime
we all have to cover each other
i love it
he was so pissed about that when that
generalist asked him oh yeah well he's
dead so it doesn't matter oh my god
it's also important to note that bill
gates is not a medical doctor he is
though heavily invested in vaccines and
in pfizer with the bill and linda gates
uh putting a bunch of their money into
that investing it into that specific uh
you know treatment but
another thing to kind of really uh talk
about here um is the fact that
wait i forgot the exact point because i
was like trying to mimic his voice again
i lost my train of thought uh this is
what happens when you try to do
impersonations yeah it's very
distracting i've never done them before
so that was pretty good throwing me in
the water but that was a weird way to
impersonate bill gates
wonderful that's what it seemed like
life would return to normal
outfitted from a little bit of the
rubbing of the hands you know the
ringing under
oh yeah yeah the point i wanted to make
is that there are other medical
professionals that are saying that
omnicron could be the best possible
scenario for the world as it could lead
to a lot of natural immunity as it is
very transmissive but it's uh not lethal
and it will prove to have less
hospitalizations for most people that's
some of the thinking going out there by
some medical professionals who are
saying this could mean the end of kovid
the end of all of this and they see it
ending in a span of three months as of
course everyone gets it and no you know
a lot of people don't have severe
illnesses because of it it is so
frustrating to me watching this omicron
thing because this is exactly what a
virus does it starts out super intense
like we saw in china becomes a little
less intense a little more infectious
now it's super infectious and not super
intense this should be great news but
we're not allowed to think it is this is
why we're dispensing a whole bunch of
tests so we can be like oh my gosh i'm
infected i have to be careful i have to
get the vaccination well there's a lot
of fear mongering out there but if you
look at the cases yes they're going up
but if you look at the debts for the
last three months they have been
steadily going down and still continue
to go down if you pull up the debts
right now the data is showing that there
isn't a correlation with high cases and
high debts as their previously was
beforehand so it's it's highlighting
that that hypothesis by some scientist
is coming to be true does anyone does
that express the the reason they're
focused solely on cases yeah i mean
there's been a lot of that throughout
the whole pandemic but right now it's
really about cases and that's why tests
which is something you're bringing up
and if you pull up google you can look
up the the cases and their debts and
there's a big
you know
difference between them now any
candidate who runs on a return to
normalcy is going to win yep so the
democrats are going to be like they're
going to be holding up their end is nice
signs on the street frantic
and there's going to be some republican
being like i'm going to get your schools
open again
and then people are going to be like yes
i'm talking about 2022 though oh yeah
yeah you're gonna have in these i think
this is the reason a lot of democrats
are retiring one of them there's a lot
of political reasons one of them's
probably i'm sure that they're they're
talking to their consultants and they're
like listen
what plays well among democrats which
you need to win
is pandemic lockdown vaccines
but among moderates and republicans that
is very very bad which means you can't
win
because if you come out and you support
the democrat position you're going to be
representing just a third of the country
of your district and you will lose but
if you come out as a democrat and say we
should get back to normal you'll lose
that third and moderates won't be enough
to get you the to get you elected your
best bet is leaving run somewhere else
but that's horrible advice like isn't i
remember somebody i can't remember which
commentator mentioned this but like they
were saying that you need to have
somebody sane in the democrat party and
there's actually there could be a place
for people like that you know i don't
not anymore no no no 2018 2020 was was
an opportunity i mean look i supported
uh i think i donated to four different
democrats because i was like get some
sanity in this party get some like they
rejected it yeah they were they rejected
they don't they don't want any of that
they they are
too pathetic to stand up to the cult
so they they quit so they're quitting in
huge numbers
every democrat there's not one soul
in the town of sodom and gomorrah that
can actually tulsi gabbard
spoke up against a lot of the stuff and
they excised her from the party
look at look at how they they refer to
like the people who come on this show
who it's like it's like you know center
left to right wing individuals and most
comments we don't get any far leftists
for the most part they rarely come on
but they're like if you you know that
vosh calls me a conservative literally
in a video where i say abolish the
police and he goes thank you tim and i'm
like so what's what is what does
conservative mean to you yeah like
that's a cult i'm sorry if they are
unwilling to accept anybody anybody at
all unless you're marching in lockstep
the democrats realize they can't win
yeah the the younger democrat that is
coming to the party is is a zealous
cult-like base
they can't win well they're that's such
a different strategy and they're also
just asking for more and more and more
and they're not given much except for
trump was bad i'm like oh okay what are
you running on what are you gonna do
trump is bad is not a policy and i think
a lot of people need to realize that
because a lot of americans are saying
hey we're being screwed we're being
robbed like we're paying for all these
tests now what who's going to be paying
for that they're saying it's free test
it's not nothing the government does is
free
and when something is free you're
usually the product but in this case
your taxes or the money that's going to
be inflated is going to be paying for
that and and either way you're going to
be paying for it one way or another i
want to bring up this story from the
other day it's uh many of you may have
seen it trump and bill o'reilly got
booed after telling audience they got
booster shots and then trump is like no
no no don't do that you're playing
anything blah blah and i'm like
what's funny about this story is that
many on the left are like haha trump got
boosted and i'm like okay like i don't
i'm i'm not mad i don't care
he's an older guy maybe that made sense
for him sure but they live in this
bubble world where they think all of
trump supporters are in a cult yes all
of his voters are cultists meanwhile
it's like
most of his base is kind of like
whatever and then some are like that's
stupid and they boo him but
i don't know i don't care
bill o'reilly can trump they can do
whatever they want but this actually
debunks a lot of that narrative
that's why i just think it's funny
shouldn't they be like wow hey wait a
minute i was told that trump's base are
all a bunch of zealot maga q and on
people but there are actually people who
aren't agreeing with him and he himself
is vaccinate is boosted
there's a disconnect between
trump's supposed to be this cult leader
right right well being the genius
marketer that he is as soon as that as
soon as that little pocket of booze
happened he goes very small group of
people right over there anyway
but also during his speech he was making
a lot of assertions based off no data no
information at all he said this would
have been like the spanish flu if it
wasn't for me we got to take credit i
want credit we got credit for for doing
this what did what did you do
after your you know your product that
you stream rolled and you threw a lot of
money into uh got out there what
happened case has gone up debts have
gone up you know what are you dancing on
like how are you going to be making all
these assertions um and a lot of people
aren't happy with his statements and i
think you know his statements and what
he did with dr fauci is going to lead to
a situation where a lot of his supporter
base i think legitimately is not going
to be following him now the corporate
media saying that he's an anti-vaxxer
and all of his followers or anti-vaxxers
again it's just hyperbolic dribble
because he's he's clearly on a different
side and and clearly not afraid to
express those ideas you see that that
interview he did where he said he didn't
fire fouchy because the left would have
lost it and then a bunch of people on
the right were like trump admits he
didn't fire fauci because he was scared
of the left the left already lost it a
number of times during his entire
presidency and with absolute nonsense
trump should have realized his people
around him should have realized hey you
can't appease any of these people they
want
war but there might be something else
hanging in the balance here because
today we also found out that trump flew
on uh epstein's plane six more times
than previously believed so if you're
hanging out with epstein who's an
extortionist who's a blackmailer there
could be also something something else
happening behind the scenes that could
translate into this kind of uh
misunderstanding and trump you know
pushing a lot of policies that are very
in favor of the establishment that
essentially do hurt the general public
and the middle class i like the
conspiracy theory that trump was part of
the establishment the whole time
because what he was able to do as a
candidate was get people like alex jones
to support a republican candidate for
the presidency and to get a whole bunch
of the people who are not attached
politically to join the political frame
join a party and become part of that
system
right yeah absolutely and and you know
when it comes to politics it's dirty
there's a lot of other things happening
behind the scenes there's a lot of
special interest there's a lot of
multinational corporations throwing
around a lot of money there's a lot of
blackmail going around as well so i
don't think we're seeing the full actual
story here of what's actually going on
and that's just my own perspective i
could be wrong uh prove prove me wrong
if you think i'm wrong but um again
what what trump has done is something
that i haven't uh been supportive of
i've criticized him ever since he sat
down with henry kissinger he promised a
lot in my opinion he definitely under
delivered but that's my perspective i
know a lot of people are going to be
disagreeing with me but that's okay
that's that's your perspective prove me
wrong with some data and some facts uh
but that's how i saw it myself
personally and i think a lot of other
people who are paying attention to the
news to the reality of the situation are
also feeling the same way because how
can you not especially with you know
julian assange is the kind of cherry on
top right but trump trump was just an
imperfect avatar for people's anger
right you know so when bernie sanders
lost he a lot of bernie supporters voted
for trump and this is something that the
progressives will never want to admit
but it's true i was in anaheim
california and there were three dudes
one was older two were younger and they
were explaining that you know they were
trump supporters but they were bernie
supporters until hillary stole the you
know
are they until until the dnc
you know went in favor of hillary or put
it that way
and uh they got physically attacked
the the people there started attacking
them and they were running and they were
spitting on them and stuff like that and
it's really amazing this guy said he was
a bernie supporter he said he felt
bernie had more experience that bernie
was a politician and trump was not and
that bernie would know how to navigate
these systems bernie was in favor of
border security bernie was in favor of
helping the working class but as soon as
hillary came in he was like nope donald
trump's the answer because you know
hillary clinton is going to be open
borders hillary clinton is going to be
all of the worst things war conflict you
know extracting our jobs and placing
them overseas trump was the only option
trump was talking about investigating
911 holding saudi arabia accountable for
it auditing the federal reserve
releasing the jfk cia documents
everyone's mind was blown he was like
he's bucking the system really and then
you know the reality of of all those
promises was was a lot you know when he
was an officer about bucking the system
yeah
very well
it's because trump flying in his plane
over dc looking down at the world and
then telling everybody i am going to
clean this place up is very different
from when the plane lands and he takes
one step and his foot sinks three feet
into muck and scum and he goes like what
do i do here
it happens to a lot of these these
people run they say i'm gonna do all
these things
i'm gonna do this that or otherwise and
then trump gets in and he was
like just dredging through that muck
trying to make it to the other side
worse still
with a lot of presidents they get in the
muck they they don't follow through on
all their promises
trump not only had the muck but he had
the establishment democrat and activists
you know like lassoing him and pulling
him back at the same time and they're
still doing it today throughout his
entire presidency he was being in
presidency he was investigated then he
would they impeached him and they
impeached him again then you get ukraine
gay russia gate all of these scandals
preventing him from being able to do
anything and the left likes it they're
like good obstruct him but i'll tell you
this you cannot have a country where all
you have is two sides obstructing each
other and nothing's getting done because
eventually when the obstruction stops
working people start hitting each other
that sounds like a dream for me
government obstructing each other not
doing anything that sounds awesome i
have a difference they rip each other
apart um
well if you know if they don't let one
side get too strong to hurt the other
side if they just keep keeping each
other in check i think that would be the
optimal situation i don't see that
happening i see them more working in
tandem and from my perspective you know
trump got in that swamp he was like okay
i'll fight this a little bit and then
like midway he's like oh this is a mud
bath this is nice and he started rubbing
the
the the dc mud all over himself and kind
of enjoying it and then be like maybe i
should uh it's kind of nice just being
in this money i think i think one way to
put it is trump's always had a bit of a
muck on him yeah i mean
when he got into the swamp he looked at
some swamp monsters and one swamp
monster was like trump hydra
and then trump was like
he goes wait a minute are you a sweat
monster i swear i'm not
okay john and then he looks over at
another swamp monster and he's like i'm
gonna invade iran and he's like you're
hired
and fauci was there the whole time and
trump was like i'd fire that sweat
monster but the p the swamp monsters
over there really like him so i won't
yeah and jared kushner as well i mean
there's a lot of crazy stories that came
out surrounding jared kushner and his
involvement and sphere of influence
pushing a lot of policies that were
absolutely not popular at all and there
was a lot of opportunity there and i i
think that's why a lot of people felt
let down but let's be honest here he
still did some okay things uh we
shouldn't be too
uh one-sided and and not just always
attack him we should admit that he also
did push for very populous policies he
had a very uh unique china policy no new
awards he focused on american jobs and
again we have to start seeing things
through the lens of of uh outside of our
political gangs you know what's funny
though no you shouldn't be the bloods
you shouldn't be the crips but you
should see that this violence is just
absolutely stupid and then both sides
are playing you i'll tell you what's
funny is that trump did try to end a lot
of our wars yeah but not all of them he
did try to get us out of the middle east
and stuff like that it's kind of sad
that where we are as a country is the
president who doesn't start any new wars
gets praise because we're so used to all
the president's starting wars that's the
norm yeah yeah and and i understand
trump was actually pulling back a little
bit but imagine if we got a president on
day one just signed a bunch of executive
orders saying we hereby are ending these
excursions and we're gonna be bringing
troops back and we're gonna be
withdrawing all that stuff even trump
didn't do that but trump did i believe
try in many ways and that's because when
he was you know
marching through the muck and everyone
and he's trying really hard to get
through it he was determined i am going
to carry out my promise i'm going to
build that wall i'm going to you know
withdraw from afghanistan and then as
soon as he
leaves the swamp and joe biden walks
back in joe biden started rolling around
like a like a pig in
ish if you know what i mean he was happy
he was like oh swamp i'm home
you know start getting his energy back
as the swamp returned life to his you
know rotting corrupt body and then he
was like let's botch afghanistan so he
can destabilize the region further and
then there you go but continuing that
syria policy was just insane continuing
the yemen policy also another thing no
one really talks about the worst
humanitarian crisis according to many
international organizations in the world
because of the us saudi arabian
coalition that's literally fighting
proxy iranian forces against proxy al
qaeda saudi arabian forces we were on
the side of al qaeda even though
associated press was writing articles
saying how yeah you know the the saudi
coalition comes in there they tell al
qaeda to step back they bring in the
media they say we conquered al-qaeda
meanwhile they were working with them in
yemen and part of american foreign
policy as well as you know being on the
side of the rebel groups i mean bombing
syria it was just the wild his foreign
policy because he himself called himself
a globalist and a populist you can't be
both and i think he
he represented both ideas but he also
contradicted himself a lot and fought
himself let's talk about the guy i
should have fired oh yeah back to fouchy
from timcast.com fox news standing by
jesse waters after dr anthony fauci
called for his firing oh my fox news has
defended the five host jesse waters
after dr dr anthony fauci wants him
fired the controversy began after waters
told the crowd at last weekend's turning
point usa to ambush fauci with questions
project veritas style to see in public
and he mentioned going for the kill shot
and then i gotta say i don't even know
if we can read what he said i get it's
euphemism what jesse waters said but
seriously considering the way they're
reacting it's it's it's pretty overt you
know um the the the metaphors he was
using so referring to an ambush
referring to a kill shot saying things
like
boom he is dead stuff like that but we
understand that he was he was being
bombastic jesse waters was trying to get
a rise in my opinion by saying
ambush him get these questions ask him
this that or otherwise and boom or or
whatever fauci went awful went off dr
anthony fauci says fox news is jesse
waters should be fired on the spot for
telling a crowd to ambush him but he
adds he's going to go very likely
unaccountable i mean whatever network he
is on is not going to do anything for
him and my my response to this is shut
up fouch you scumbag you know these
people on cnn on new day are like why
won't anyone hold them accountable and
i'm like look in the mirror for two
seconds you morons i'm so sick of these
people they march around screaming and
smashing and and there's riots and they
celebrate and kamalaires bails these
people out she donates to them and then
the staffer biden bail out these riots
and then the moment you get one one
jesse waters being like ambush it with
some questions they're like
okay you know what i don't care i have
look the divide in this country is too
much there's there's no way to rectify
this if the right keeps capitulating
like every single time a member of
congress says something off color
they're like fire you know uh remove
them from their committees and they do
yep and lauren bobert apologizes to
ellen omar for her joke meanwhile
illinois can tweet over and over again
you know really weird statements that
make it seem like she's talking about
jewish people and they're like we don't
care they're going to keep doing it no
one's going to hold them accountable and
they live in this bubble world where all
the republicans must fall in line with
them and the funny thing is most many of
the republicans just do they do because
they care more about the opinion of the
new york times than they do about their
own constituents well maybe that will
change when y'all go out in the
primaries this spring and summer and
vote all the incumbents out and send
them back home and say you're fired
in that particular voice especially like
that yeah i do have to say it is very
bold to see dr fauci calling for a media
accountability right you know mr mr gain
of function himself he also went on and
also attacked rfk junior who just wrote
a new book about him uh he said it's
quote strange how they go unchecked with
no consequences for people to say that
and and again he's particularly
referring to rfk jr and his book the
real anthony fauci that details a lot of
very dangerous incredulous studies that
dr fauci committed throughout his years
at nih that targeted orphans children
that targeted monkeys that chartered it
uh you know puppies and and the history
of dr fauci especially from the aids
epidemic is something that's worth
noting worth understanding and to attack
rfk junior for for making a book on it
because he tries to make people
understand who people are dealing with
is is absolutely crazy um
what what ranking do you think the real
anthony fauci is on amazon
uh number one it's number one yup number
one the number one best seller in books
acro just number one the real anthony
fauci the last time i tried to get a
copy it said they weren't temporarily
unavailable the book yeah really yeah i
don't know if that's still the case but
what we got here
it says temporarily out of stock
wait wait hold on aren't these made to
order like
you order it and they print it and i
mean that was kind of a red flag for me
i was just like interesting so i'd
really like to read this book i mean i
understand the validity of it i
understand what it's
because like i listened to an interview
with rfk junior and he talked about the
250 000 some citations that he has in
this book and he also challenged
somebody like fauci or anybody that he
implicates for the crimes that he
alleges in this book to debate him on
stage
i mean he seems to understand what he's
talking about i haven't read the book
i've just heard an interview about it
3327 reviews all five stars yeah well he
gets a ton
of five star wow let's let's take a look
at one of the one star reviews
they say uh this is delusional pathetic
um if your family and friends don't hate
you after you f and find you tolerable
read this book you will lose friends and
be lafted by saying people your iq is
not going to lower itself
that's crazy but rfk junior is not a
crackpot he's a trial lawyer interesting
like well hey that's why it's so heavily
they've been saying it what else do you
guys have the truth about covet and
another bestseller
flags of corruption he's like it's kind
of crazy that this book took off like
this you know uh because it means it's
got real natural pull people want to
read this they want to know the truth
and they trust this guy no i'm not
saying i i don't know a whole lot about
him to be honest but uh if he's writing
books
look
he's gonna be he's gonna have influence
people are gonna read it in fact he's
not gonna be happy about it we'll put
that away yep the last interview that i
heard he was begging for somebody to
find a factual error he said look we are
going to do a second edition if anybody
can point out one factual error in this
book we will do a second edition we will
revise it we will point out the error
that we made and we will put it out
there to the public to review again and
if you lie about someone they could be
sued dr factory could sue rfk jr
especially with the attacks that he's
blaming rfk junior for but he hasn't
he's he's just attacking him in the
media saying yeah he's he's causing me
to have death threats no he's
criticizing you he's going through your
history and giving people a fair
perspective outside of the corporate
media that's worshipping him uh fauci
was on msnbc just a couple hours ago and
the and the anchor if you could even
call him that i'd you know this
professional bootlegger was like thank
you for your service you're the hardest
working human being in america thank you
thank you are you ever going to stop and
dr fought you was like i'm never going
to stop i love doing this and i'm like
you got to be freaking kidding me it was
more like an adult
film than it was an interview it sounds
like it was a prayer yeah a prayer to
saint faunci
it was absolutely disgusting to see this
kind of level of groveling towards
authority instead of holding it
accountable dr fauci is a political
figure he has made kovit political from
the very beginning he has not done
interviews with anyone questioning him
not done interviews with anyone saying
hey this is an opposing viewpoint let's
address it let's let's deal with half of
america that doesn't believe me by going
to their networks by talking to them and
rationally explaining what's going on
here and many other people in the public
field did a way better job addressing a
lot of important issues compared to him
that's hyper partisan super political
and from the very beginning was using
this for political power which he has
been
telling you lockdown protests are bad
blm protests are good that's insane
that's crazy but fauci really embodies
government really well
like failure after failure after failure
and he just fails up i think
highest paid bureaucrat that's that's
exactly gonna say
more specifically he embodies what a
useless bureaucrat does he can totally
misinterpret a criticism and make it
sound like he is the victim and clutches
pearls and then say some nonsense words
and then the criticism just evaporates i
just like him i just love how he
responded to rand paul you know rand
paul's like you did gain a function
research and the analogy i like is you
know you go dr fauci did you install a
door in this room we did not put a door
in the room it is simply a thin piece of
wood with a knob that when you turn it
pulls a latch which allows the paddle to
be opened making it easier for you to
access the room and it's on hinges and
you're like you just described a door it
is not a door the best part
the best part about it is rand paul's
sip of water
lies to his face that sip of water is
like his eyes are giant he's just like
you know it reminds me of it's like it
reminds me of you walk in the kitchen
it's like you know midnight and you've
got like a small kid there and he's on
he's on a chair and he's got the ice
cream in his hand and there's chocolate
over his face
and you're like you know rand paul is
like
doc doctor you know
son you've got ice cream all over your
face did you take the ice cream and he's
like
no
it's like
what i'm literally looking at on your
face it's not ice cream i it's uh
soup it's just chocolate dairy
sugar
that's ice cream kid yeah he he
literally tried to cancel christmas and
then he backtracked when people were
like hey this is absurd like why are you
even making these kind of crazy comments
trying to control people's lives exactly
what they were like we're mad at you now
he was like okay you can have christmas
back
that's insane i love that
you see that meme where it's a bunch of
uh uh people wearing masks with like
face shields and it says normal people
and then below it's a bunch of smiling
people eating christmas dinners
conspiracy theorists
that's the crazy thing to me man yeah
because i got like i know so many people
where they're just like
who was it it was um what's his face
from queen
brian may is that him he got he got
mercury no brian may he got he got a
covet but he's triple vaxxed and his
immediate response was make sure you get
your vaccine and i'm like dude dude dude
stop stop stop um because i'm not here
to talk science i'm just here to say
that you're the last person who should
be advocating for that tell people to go
talk to a doctor because if you are like
elizabeth warren or cory booker or brian
mayer jim cramer and you are like i've
been triple vexed and i've got coveted
two you should get the vaccine i'm like
dude you are anti-promoting the vaccine
by doing that
well you're discouraging it and what
kind of message are you sending yeah
yeah and you know what they say they
just say i'm sure it would have been
worse if i hadn't had this shot well
you're running a parallel universe in
that instance you have no idea what it
would be like if you hadn't had this
shot you'd probably still have gotten
well we don't we don't we don't know we
don't know we don't know what he did
you got joe biden coming out and he's
like you know it was it was the covid
protocol guy who said there's going to
be a winter of death
you know for the unvaccinated and a lot
of people were tweeting like this is not
how you convince people and i'm like
it's true it's not how you convince
people but let's be real i don't think
there's any convincing left to be done
i do not believe at this point there's
anything anyone's going to say to
convince someone to go and get the
vaccine or you know like i i just i
think it's a way it's a pointless
argument people have made up their minds
yeah and so they're resorting to threats
yeah yeah i mean there's no more
convincing to be done so that's what
happens you can't convince somebody okay
well maybe you threaten them and
extortion and manipulation as literally
talked about by the mayor of new york
city who says we're gonna have to take
away people's ability to get a paycheck
to eat and that's how we're to get them
to do this or find them like they're
doing in austria and and literally steal
money from them and bring jack thugs in
there with badges and shine and fancy
uniforms to threaten their lives to do
so and i think that's not a way i want
to live in and that's against human
rights and that's that violates every
core principle of our current
civilization and it's leading to a very
dangerous one where top-down bureaucrats
have too much control of your life and i
don't want to live in that kind of
existence all right
i wanna i wanna talk about something
very serious oh yeah i am deeply
offended and i'm going to start this
segment by saying one thing
i could be watching a movie
right and it's an action movie maybe a
james bond film and you know the the
action hero pulls out his gun and just
shoots a bunch of dudes and they die
i feel nothing
but that scene when the dog gets to buy
a car
then i'm like
john wick
exactly yeah oh like john wick just went
around slaughtering people and you're
just like yeah you get him why because
they killed his dog
from the independent
bidens have given away dog major to
family friends after biting incidents
first family of the united states is
re-homing their dog
citing that it would be safest for major
yo that's some dark stuff like i get it
sometimes people have to do stuff like
this but the reality is they use the dog
as a prop joe biden's got a strong dog
and then the dog bites people like get
rid of them quick yeah i tweeted about
this like if you don't have time to
raise a dog profit really you shouldn't
be getting more dogs and to give one
away i mean that probably breaks the
heart of the dog that that totally is
just disrespectful
nasty
irresponsible behavior
and and you know if you have a dog
that's troubled you have to train them
again i'm a dog owner i also have german
shepherds german shepherds are the
second leading breed of dog that uh are
related to attacks you know when you
have a dog like that it's like having a
gun
when you have a gun you need to be
responsible for it you need to learn how
to use it you need to make sure that
you're not going to hurt anyone else
with that i took you know my you know
my dog parenting very seriously i train
my dog i run my dog almost every single
day
you have to because they're they're
creatures that deserve all of your time
and if you're a bureaucrat that clearly
one is not right up there not all there
health-wise you think you're going to
have another dog that you're dog
responsible for of course that other
dog's going to be biting more people but
they got another dog that's crazy they
just replaced it for a new dog named for
a new puppy
i don't believe for a minute that this
dog was re-homed i think this is pure
propaganda i have no facts to back this
claim up but what i think is that that
dog took one look at uh you know 90 year
old joe biden chasing him out of the
shower and he ran and never came back
i think remember that story right i
remember yeah he slipped in the shower
or whatever the yeah that dog was out of
there he was just like i don't need this
i don't need this i know they spent 20
years ahead of me you know dogs can
smell uh seizures before they happen
yeah
so that's crazy dogs can smell cancer
what if dogs can smell evil
and like joe biden is in like you know
the conservatory or whatever they have
in the white house and like the dogs in
the in the corner like
snarling and joe budden's like stop
snarling we have to do a photo shoot and
the dog's like and then like get rid of
him and so they bring in this puppy and
the puppies too too confused and doofy
to yeah you know understand that he's
the the the odor coming off him is evil
pure evil
quite possible i can see that that makes
sense to me yeah that checks out yep i
heard that i heard that dogs can smell
if you've eaten dog
i believe that yeah i had heard that i
have rumors about that i haven't heard
if that's true but they're extremely
intuitive they're extremely smart
especially german shepherds they know
what's going on um and and if you don't
raise them right they could be some of
the worst dogs that you could ever have
and they are
they have a tendency to to lash out and
be angry especially when you don't pay
attention to them especially if you
don't give them a lot of time um and to
see these kind of dogs use this use this
props and to just be thrown away it's
it's sick and disgusting irresponsible
behavior and i wouldn't expect anything
else from the federal government they
get a fake dog so they can be like look
we got a dog
no they got they got a new dog named
commander or whatever which is another
german shepherd right yeah yeah yep the
same uh same kind of yo german shepherds
need training yep a lot of training and
a lot of exercise i have a german
shepherd i love my german chocolate
aren't they like the closest breed to
wolves or something yes i was reading
about this so for joe biden to be like
we want a prop dog and they probably had
a consultant come in and be like now
german shepherds you know they they they
test very very well in our pulse so you
can either go with a husky or a german
shepherd
don't do the labradoodle and they're
like we'll go with the german shepherd
he's like well now german shepherds
require a lot of training and joe
biden's like
yeah you want to look tough that's why
you want to have a german shepherd
and you know it's great marketing but
but again a huge responsibility and
there's so much training to go into
trump i get a labradoodle yeah
pug i think
pugs also great what if trump just had
like two massive pit bulls with them all
the time like just super huge and they
walk to his left and his right and
they're just like
that'd be pretty awesome like the gold
chain
the babylon bee had a great headline
saying the bidens are going to name
their dog carl barks which is it's right
on the money they're over
um but disappointed to see so many dogs
just kind of thrown away and and it's
bad for especially german shepherds
german shepherds are dogs that need an
alpha need a primary owner and if they
don't and if they keep getting kind of
thrown around between different owners
and they don't kind of have uh their one
owner
they get lost and confused and they're
not happy dogs when they don't have that
one person in their life that they have
to serve look at this story is kind of
sickening to me
npr the biden say hello to new puppy
commander and major is off to a new home
and then they have this tweet meet the
newest biden welcome home commander it's
just like they threw out one dog and
bought another one of the same breed
yeah
that's exactly what happened
well that's uh that's how joe biden will
treat you
as an american that's right no no wait
people are asking that my dog bite
michael mouse no that wasn't my dog
i traded my i trained my dog yeah and
yeah yeah when we were doing the uh the
crazy show michael had the thing on his
face yeah cause nick's dog bit his face
yeah yeah i didn't know what it was and
then
bit my dog that's right and right this
ripped her face too yeah and oh my god
but that's um what is that is that a
husky
um i think it's a shepherd mix of some
sort
you gotta train your dogs man absolutely
people think this is a joke and you can
get a puppy
and joe biden's doing it again how much
you want to bet commander goes off and
bites somebody in what six months i am
i'm gonna place money on that and i
think part of the reason that um major
wasn't happy with joe biden was because
he's a terrible leader and it turns out
that he actually is for the rest of the
country as well but he probably didn't
respect him as like
well germans you with german shepherds
you need an alpha right you need someone
who's confident because if the german
shepherd sees that you're not confident
they're gonna try to walk all over you
like atlas challenges me my dog
challenges me all the time i'm like no
no you're not gonna get away with this
it's not gonna work here uh but but if i
kind of let loose and don't train her
and and and you know
don't do the proper work with her she's
not going to obviously be a good dog and
she's going to be disrespectful and and
obviously biden doesn't have time to
raise a dog right now so there's no way
that german shepherd is going to be
raised properly um and then as you
mentioned tim german shepherds are very
much like uh wolves and i had a dog
trainer say if you want to understand
german shepherds just watch
documentaries about wolves
and i did and there's a huge learning
curve fascinating animals but again it's
just like anything
they also have a potential to be very
dangerous
you need to be responsible for it people
are going to get hurt dogs are going to
get hurt it's it's not being a jerk it's
not just that it's take responsibility
for for the animals you have you know
what i mean like if you get a dog that's
your problem you got to figure it out
but joe biden clearly got the dog as a
prop that's the thing
well you mentioned that maybe like how
he treated the former biden dog is how
he's going to treat us what if it's not
maybe we're looking at this sideways
here what if it he's actually worried
it's not about controlling where the dog
is it's about the dog's safety that's
why he re-homed it
sure sure that's what's not safe for
sure yeah maybe maybe not control we do
need to be secure yeah maybe he could
get some pugs and teach them how to do
the the black power paw oh it'd be great
yeah
well it was a little bit more severe
than the black power plant no he did a
second iteration
and he and and that video was was way
funnier than the first one oh okay
so i haven't watched it yet but i need
to watch that you haven't seen it it's
actually i saw that i've seen the first
one yeah i got him in trouble yeah so
the second one he did is like he's he's
you know he's got the teaching the dog
or whatever one elsa needs a knock on
the door and he's like he's like oh crap
it's the labor party and then he like
has to hide a bunch of books
one of the book he has to hide is the
torah yeah
oh my gosh because you know
you know because they're anti-semites
yeah man that's funny i think this is an
example of um
it's a combination of callousness
and um
i think it exemplifies a lot about what
uh like the administration has been in
terms of their like
what's the right word i'm trying to
think of just like their capacity you
know what i mean like biden i don't
think if he was running against anybody
else would ever win right but because
there were so many people who didn't
like trump people were like i'll take
whatever i can get the corporeal form
they called it right well what do you
get with that you get weak leadership
you get callousness you get lazy
uh behavior and you're gonna you can get
joe biden uh half measures
and you're gonna get a whole bunch of
people bit and hurt that's right and
a whole bunch of you know dogs that
don't have a true you know owner and uh
have a horrible life should we get like
should we get like one of those pools
where you like put dates and then we
figure out like how long it's gonna last
and everyone can buy a square and we'll
be like this is gonna last three months
yep this dog's gonna become you know at
six months and they're gonna be like oh
look you know joe biden what was the
story about him in the bathtub the
shower or whatever he slipped well i
mean oh he broke his foot or something
right yeah he liked
the story was so bizarre like i can't
remember all the details but basically
they said that he was trying to pet the
dog after a shower and he fell down and
he hurt himself
none of it added up and it all created
really horrifying imagery that i won't
forget yeah some people said it was a
cover-up for a bigger medical procedure
dealing with his brain and aneurysms and
that's why he had this cover story that
was so elaborative that didn't make any
sense at all yeah but what's the
evidence for that
a lot of speculation and theories and
and the fact that he also has very
serious injuries still within his head
uh i believe it's what correct me from
wrong metal stints two metal stints in
his head yeah he had two what do you
have aneurysms or something yeah yeah
but this was like decades and decades
ago so yeah but there could be some yeah
there it's it needs to be checked up on
there needs to be some very serious
procedures that people need to take
that's associated with that and you
think joe biden gets blood infusions
from children probably yeah
that's the basic stuff it's probably
even bigger than that well so i mean i
mean i bring that up because i know
it'll be very triggering to a lot of
people on the left they're going to be
like oh don't say that that's conspiracy
but we know a lot of rich people and
powerful individuals they get they get
blood transfusions from young people and
so like a lot of these billionaires
actually hire bodybuilders to like just
go to the gym and be a gym rat eat
healthy and then once every two weeks
they get a blood infusion from their not
just whatever blood but also fecal
matter there's also
people there's a south park episode
about that exactly
and there is science behind that that
blood uh kind of therapy that is
implemented in some parts of mexico
already and there are a lot of
billionaires financing more scientific
discoveries and studies into that and it
wouldn't surprise me we don't have any
kind of evidence it's kind of
circumstantial to kind of allude that
this could be happening but uh you know
there's some probability that yes that's
that's probably what's going on there
that's probably what's going on with
henry kissinger and a whole bunch of
other stuff that they're getting that
gives them life extension technology and
allows them to live all the way up until
the 80s and 90s
i mean david rockefeller was 101. let's
talk about this uh this very obvious
article from timcast.com the headline
should be just duh but it's um half of
democrats and 70 of all voters say
inflation is affecting their family
budget
bolsters it is an asked voters if the
current rate of inflation is affecting
your family budget and yes broken down
by gender male and female responses were
nearly identical with 74.5 percent of
men and 74.6 percent of women saying yes
amazing
when looking at location all regions of
the country had almost identical
responses clearly inflation is having a
very broad impact across the country
irrespective of who you are how old you
are where you live what your politics
are in the level of your education so
subhead duh for this article but why is
it why is it getting worse why is it
that it seems to be only the republicans
are like hey stop spending and the
democrats are like spend more
well that's because there's a big
transfer of wealth and people extorting
a national tragedy for their personal
benefit and the benefit of their friends
in the multinational corporations that
are robbing this country blind as of
course it's a sinking ship that's going
down very dramatically fast and before
kovid there was one person worth over
100 billion dollars now there's nine 10
of the richest people before covid were
worth 695 billion dollars now they're
worth
1.36 trillion dollars well let's take
let's let's think about that for a real
quick second
do we think the lockdowns are going to
get worse i vote yes yeah yeah um it
could go either way i think there's a
probability that
uh omnicron could be the best case
scenario and could be the end of this
there's a possibility there's a
possibility they exploit the
transvisibility and say it's getting
worse so i think it'll get worse what do
you think do you think you vote worse or
better
i'm right on the razor's edge there it's
really hard to say yeah uh
white pill it's gonna get better it's
gonna get better yeah so then you wanna
short
amazon ah
that's why i'm on the edge here i'm not
trying to give any stock advice the
stock market is a positive scheme yeah
yeah i'm saying that the the the royal
you we whatever yeah an individual
if it is going to get better you want to
short
amazon stock because people are going to
start shopping other businesses will
start popping up they'll be competition
but if it's going to get worse amazon
stock is going to keep going through the
roof moderna stock pfizer stock so you
too can be a billionaire just like you
know these these these big tech moguls
and everything like that who who bought
a bunch of this stock nancy pelosi just
just invested what she invests in she
knows what's up right what is she
investing we should have a stock ticker
of everything she's she's doing every
single day just so
just to kind of like call it out even
more but it's pretty crazy what's
happening in the financial world because
like we know it's bad but it's a lot
worse than we're even being told right
now and shocking the levels of money
that's just being printed with the touch
of a button and how much of that money
is going into private hands like
blackrock roblox pelosi's got 10 000
shares in roblox what
she's got crowdstrike
that's not surprising what's crowdstrike
crowdstrike uh it's a security let me
let me make sure i can read it very
specifically as to what they say it is
crowdstrike provides cloud-based
software using security of computers
servers and mobile phones the stock
pulled a bit back blah blah blah crowd
strike was just
the i don't want i want to be careful
for legal reasons but very much
associated with a lot of the stories
about democrats and
i do remember that yeah right right
right
let's see what else they got they got uh
she's she got a tesla what does she have
she has uh mandatory files in january
show pelosi exercise 25 call options on
tesla
um let's see there we go
nvidia
really interesting nvidia netflix that
seems like a a no-brainer and is that
all is that all the time well you got to
continue oh you got to click to continue
what is this insider monkey paypal
oh here we go now it's going to do the
thing
she got apple what else she got she's
got alphabet uh she's got microsoft
and she's got facebook
i mean she's betting on big tech no
she's betting on lockdowns yeah she is
nancy pelosi everything she bought there
some of them are obvious but she's
invested in companies that are very
important for lockdowns computer
security yes
well i'm not super worried i'm not
saying like literally everything but the
stuff she's invested in these big tech
companies
what are people going to be doing under
lockdown they're going to be using
computers they're going to be on
facebook alphabet google
uh apple inc they're going to be
watching netflix you got to get them in
the meta version paypal is going to be
digital uh transactions
right so i'm not saying that's that's
evidence of of you know necessarily
nvidia what does nvidia do do you guys
know what video does graphics gpus okay
so you're going to be having people play
video games yeah she's it's metaverse
baby so let's place bets about tesla
electric cars crowdstrike is just you
know whatever roblox
roblox the the wondertail stories of
children's books and infinite
possibilities of stories and worlds well
i don't know about that one but
putting kids more in video games
metaphor stuff i'm not saying all of
this is
definitive proof that she's very much
like on board with metaverse or whatever
but she's certainly invested in
companies that wouldn't be involved in a
metaverse like reality
or a lockdown reality
or you know the future of of pod living
the future of uh the metaverse oh she
doesn't have any bug companies does she
no i wouldn't be surprised i i don't
think it would be that on the nose that
obviously a little on the nose hold on a
minute you guys we know
what these people want to do right yep
you will own nothing and you'll be happy
yep what kind of company could we start
or invest in that works perfectly for
people who own nothing a sharing company
a what sharing company you share your
devices you share your clothes equipment
you share your clothes and what do they
want us to eat
so we should start bug farms dude we'll
be rich
i'll start we'll start we'll start a
farm no a cicada farm oh
my my soul wouldn't be able to to live
without yeah
you know where they're going and you
know the best part is they'll probably
subsidize it the government will be
alike this is in line with our plans
here's free money to run your business
and then you can sell all the grubs and
roaches and uh i wonder if roly-polies
taste good oh i guess pill bugs find out
aren't we there's way too much
they can figure it out you sprinkle it
on your bug cream like fungus ice cream
that doesn't have to be good it just has
to sustain you to the point where you
can
live a little bit i think it's just
going to be goo just like in the matrix
and you know and either it's just
injected into your veins or into the
back of your head or that was kind of
that was kind of dumb though because
they they if they could just plug you
into your own mini matrix like they were
doing with neo and then you could eat a
buffet
yeah and enjoy yourself you know what i
mean and i like how they're like the
brain makes it real that's stupid the
brain makes it real so what happens if
you eat a whole cake will your body like
vomit
in real life there's nothing to vomit up
bile i guess but they had to otherwise
it was just like
you know you wouldn't die in the matrix
so you know speaking of the matrix
matrix is coming out very soon in a few
hours yep in a few hours one oh yeah
yeah yeah on hbo max on hbo max 3am
eastern three a.m eastern interesting is
what they're saying are you going to
watch it uh i might just wake up just to
see it
i'm a huge matrix fan
but i i do believe this is going to be
the end of the kind of real matrix
trilogy and the introduction of the new
world order matrix trilogy that goes
along with the propaganda and narrative
and talking points of all the bull crap
that's already being shoved down our
throats that's how i see it i'm a little
pessimistic on that um but i still want
to see it because i'm a big fan of the
of the trilogy i remember when the first
movie came out i was just like whoa this
is insane i remember watching it and be
like there's so many like
representations things you know society
you know be the funniest thing ever if
in the new matrix there's a scene where
like neo is like you know like in the
trailer he's eating all the blue pills
and then he's like i gotta clear my head
so then he's like i'm gonna go to the
movies and he goes to a movie there's a
huge line of people and there's agents
scanning vacs passports
and he's like what's this is the matrix
and then they're like you know just like
jabbing at all the people who did yeah i
already did i already did one video
about my kind of theory about what was
going to be happening uh in the matrix
on my platform but i i people are
calling it the woke tricks and i think
they're going to be yeah they're going
to be like neo you weren't really the
one it's this blue-haired person that's
it's all the power non-binary yeah the
person it's the latest it was the one
the whole time and even if it is
even if it is
okay but but don't make it where you
have to shove it down people's throats
like you can make a character that's you
know whatever you want them to be but
when you overtly try to push a political
message and you stop worrying about the
kind of entertainment value of it that's
when it just gets annoying because like
we could see the subconscious propaganda
the subliminal messages you're putting
on there but when you're trying to make
it like overt for like right right right
people who are not intelligent
no the issue is people who are lacking
talent making movies that's what it
really is they're ideal logs and they
have no talent because you watch the new
ghostbusters compared to girl busters
the new ghostbusters the the new team
these four kids you've got a boy a girl
you got an asian kid and and a black you
know girl yeah it's a completely diverse
cast of young people who put on the
jumpsuits but there's no like overt you
know the white man and like patriarchy
it was literally just
they happen to be people
and they're ghost busting girl busters
was literally like a bunch of really
angry stereotypical nasty dudes and like
you know these mary sue characters doing
slapstick comedy talk about really awful
yeah yeah and again most most
entertainment is propaganda it's it's
used for uh
weaponized political purposes it's been
for a very long time that's why the cia
is so interconnected with hollywood
that's why the cia is literally out
there promoting
black panther and other another kind of
movies out there that fit their
narrative they're writing scripts in
many instances with with the military
industrial complex giving
a lot of movies and hollywood studios
favors to use a lot of their equipment
in exchange for rewriting their scripts
and always making them the good guys no
matter what the situation is they're
also rewriting this they also rewrite
the scripts for the benefit of china um
so many times in so many egregious ways
disney made a movie just trying to
appease just china in itself and to see
this layer of intervention when
something is supposed to be
entertainment something is supposed to
be pure something is supposed to be
just something that's going to inspire
you but it's used to re-educate you it's
used to change your line of thinking
it's it's it's horrible to see because a
lot of people unsuspectingly see it and
they get
influenced by it sure but i don't i
don't really care all much about that
what i care about is bad content you
know the problem with captain marvel the
problem with these these overtly
political
movies and stuff is it's just bad
content it's in it's mean it's insulting
in many ways it's off-putting right one
of the things i brought up with like the
captain marvel film is that she
literally robs a guy like she's not a
good person he he tells her to smile so
she steals his clothes and i'm just like
it's kind of villainous behavior i can't
root for her you know and so they think
they're making this powerful statement
where she like tells the man because he
said smile
and i'm like the heroes are supposed to
be like i will not be dragged into your
petty bs
so the issue is just bad content you
make a film with the female protagonist
hunger games i thought hunger game was
fantastic oh look it's a female hero you
know what i mean
but then you end up with these movies
like captain marvel or girl busters and
it's just annoying
not good like like i was saying with
ghostbusters the new one diverse cast
for the for the new ghostbusters i don't
care cool it's just a bunch of kids it
was funny the little podcast kid he was
great but the content was there that's
the main thing yeah the new ghostbusters
yeah paul rudd was hilarious yeah it
always is uh for the most part so is the
original matrix and that original series
propaganda does it qualify as propaganda
or is it just too entertaining to be
propaganda well there's a lot of
parallels to our current society that a
lot of people could make their kind of
own understandings of and their their
own kind of guesses to what it really is
in their kind of life form so i think
just that as an art form in itself is is
pretty rare and unique where you could
say oh this is you know an explanation
for this in our society and you could
have so many different explanations i
thought that was great but it was
predominantly still focused on you know
central controllers you being a battery
you being a slave you fighting the
people who are central controllers who
are extorting robbing you of your life i
thought that overall message like like a
lot of you know you know messages out
there was overall somewhat of a very
intriguing one that that was
thought-provoking um instead of just
beating you over the head of a
propaganda uh there's propaganda
everywhere everything's propaganda isn't
it isn't it better to be in the matrix
that's oblivious some people would argue
i would i would totally disagree with
you
it's like being an ostrich with your
head in the sand and you're in your butt
all the way out there ready for some
top-notch globalist to come in and do
unspeakable
uh
things with you so i prefer not to have
my head in sand i like having my but
let's let's think about this swivel
looking left how how would you feel
if all of a sudden you woke up
in this weird room and your whole life
was fake
and you have no idea where you are you
know that'd be crazy right yeah like
what would you think you know
i was wild that was crazy
no you'd be freaking out you'd be like
where am i what's going on you'd be like
my name is luke and i run a youtube
channel and then they're gonna come in
they'd be like no you don't that was
never real
you were in the matrix bro my identity
what it comes down to for me is like in
which okay whether i'm in the matrix or
not in the matrix because i was in the
matrix for a long time just totally
dialed out to everything that was
happening so i understand the the the
sort of you know
goofy sense of peace that you feel when
you're in the matrix
but i guess i i need to know where i'm
going to feel the most sense of purpose
do i feel a sense of purpose in the
matrix or am i useless or do i feel a
sense of purpose outside of the matrix
and seeing what's really happening or
not like that's what it would come down
to for me where's the sense of purpose i
think the matrix if you were in the
matrix it would be hell everything would
be perfect you would always have steak
and i think that's a lifeline that's not
yeah no the matrix they literally say
that the first iteration was perfect and
they were people rejected it so they
created an im you know a more realistic
version with suffering and humans
accepted it i'm more using it as an
example if you would put yourself in the
matrix where you would get everything
you wanted um and and if you would get
everything you would wanted you would be
miserable in my perspective that's the
argument if you didn't know
maybe let's let's let's say this
in in base reality luke is a an
overweight
short unattractive
lay about with no ambition and no drive
to fix himself so he enters his own
private you know zuckerverse you know
using the brain app and it blocks out
memories of your real life so that you
live a life where you earn all of these
things and it just so happens it all
comes to you you'd be very happy you'd
be like look at all my success you
wouldn't realize it was pre-programmed
to make you successful you'd be happy
with where you are you'd think you'd
achieved it you would need barriers of
of success you would need to work for it
in order to get it because if you were
just given it you wouldn't appreciate it
but if you had to struggle sacrifice
work hard put some blood sweat and tears
into it yes yeah and if there's a
simulation that does that that's crazy
no look in in in world of warcraft for
instance you got to put in the hours if
you want to grind for that you know
legendary or epic gear so yeah you'd
play a game it would be
let's put it this way in the real world
you know when you go out into a field
and you fight wild boars you're not very
successful with just a small dagger like
you would be in world of warcraft you
can run up to a hundred wild boars you
know at the start of warcraft if you're
playing human alliance or whatever and
you just walk up and go like oh
and the board dies go up to a wild boar
in in the real world and see what
happens
the point is video games make this a
challenge and there's there's grinding
but it's so easy
my point is you could be in the matrix
and you think you're struggling man this
video game can be hard sometimes but
come on imagine fighting a real grizzly
bear it's crazy for all you know you're
in this this matrix because you're a
layabout loser and you wanted an easy
version of life we could be literally in
the metaverse right now
in a sense i believe we are and like the
whole goal of the metaverse is to like
program people to love zuckerberg
[Laughter]
so like that's the only way to escape
the simulation is to finally accept
zuckerberg into your heart and then you
wake up and go like where am i
and then there's a big picture of mark
right in front of you like i love you
and then there's like there's two
doctors i'm like congratulations
you've escaped the simulation
there's that comic i love it where it's
a guy and he's holding the silica gel oh
my gosh and it says do not eat and he
goes those those big wigs the silica gel
factory can't tell me what to do when he
eats it and the next one is him waking
up and there's two scientists saying
congratulations you've escaped the
simulation
yeah they can't tell me what to do
yeah don't don't eat those don't do that
yeah don't they're not good what if uh
uh
you know could we talk about religion
and stuff what if what if
we're like reality is effectively a
simulation but it's a sorting algorithm
the people who are everyone's born into
a matrix and then everyone lives a life
in the matrix and then only certain
people who have certain attributes are
the ones who actually get to come out of
it and go back to base reality what if
it's effectively like some kind of
human development chamber for you know
new humans or whatever
what if after you live your life you
wake up from the matrix but you're a
baby
that is that's just real you're like
when
they're like you've lived a full life
and now you're a baby now you can apply
all that wisdom and knowledge into a new
life in base reality except for the
reincarnation aspect of that the attack
down there at the end i think that's
almost certainly the case it has
reincarnation no no
accepting that part not that yeah all
right thanks no no reincarnation but
we're almost certainly living in a
matrix like when you're born they put
you in the matrix and then
program your brain to experience like 80
years of life
and then it happens in the span of like
three months as a baby so you're like
all the babies are just like regular
people walking around and being like
whoa i'm a baby again and then like but
you grow up and you have all that
knowledge from a full life
that would be an effective society
wouldn't it
sort of i guess
but but if only some people made it out
of the matrix then you'd have a very
homogenized culture because the matrix
are effectively choosing which humans
could come out of it you know well i
mean that's the dichotomy of heaven and
hell it's two different homogenized
cultures
yeah what if like when you die if you're
like you qualify for hell it just ejects
you into a sewer pipe and if you qualify
for heaven like a metal arm picks you up
and like puts you in like a bed
certainly and then you're like you know
some people accidentally get woken up to
it and they're like god this is terrible
and they tell everybody and they're like
i saw a crazy light and it was fire and
it was awful i was like well yeah that
was the meat grinder bro
it was just dropping your
man
yeah luke's eyes just lit up
i'm looking at that
like multi multi-dimensions and all
these other energetic fields i think
there's you know a lot of things that we
don't understand i don't think we're
supposed to understand them and i think
we should be okay with that um and not
try to always you know try to see i i
need to i need to know this
maybe we don't need to know it maybe you
know i think it's better if we don't
you know oh yeah i mean there's a lot of
ambiguity there but i think that there's
something to be said for the human
spirit and i think that you basically
have a certain amount of time dedicated
to a human shell a corporeal form
and then beyond that the spirit is
liberated to one side of the matrix or
the other i mean that almost certainly
has to be the case i really believe that
well you have a choice in life you could
go right through the very you know
the light side or the dark side of the
the love or evil i think there are two
big kind of energetic forces out there
and if you give your life to one it's
going to propel you in that kind of
direction
and and you have a lot of choices you
have a lot of discernment you have a lot
of very tough decisions to make in this
life and i think those decisions will be
with you as an energetic force forever
because energy cannot be destroyed nor
created only transferred so what you
decide to do in this life is is up to
you but you know
you're giving a lot of different choices
you could either be on the side of evil
or good i choose good i try to and my
interpretations and understanding of
that and i try to do as as much good as
i can and if that's not the case then
what's the point of character yeah
what's the point of developing character
and then like maintaining character
yeah i can't think of one i can't think
of one either yeah how do you define
good
um
basic understanding of of
uh not hurting people helping people um
and
respecting their bodily autonomies
respecting their human rights this
respecting their in in in in sorry i
can't even say this correctly
inalienable rights there we go i got
that out
out there and i think not forcing people
to do something or or are hurting people
for your benefit is the other side of it
i agree with all of that but i'll i'll
offer a simpler definition good is truth
bad is lies there you go simple yeah i
like that there's truth and there's lies
what if like your mom asks you if she's
fat
you should just tell her yeah you're fat
mom you should be honest with her i mean
it's not necessarily i don't know i
don't know what if she gets
that question in the context of good
truth and bad lies
like so but
i guess i understand what you're saying
yeah like what if what if what if
there's like you know you know your
your mom buys a new dress and you think
it's tacky and she's like how do you
like my new dress i saved up what i'm so
excited and you're gonna be like it's
tacky and gross i hate it or are you
gonna be like i will lie and say i like
it because it's important to her well
there is one school of thought that
suggests that truth always pierces and
it always hurts you know there are lies
that are thin wispy skins and there is
truth which is always a dart and it's
always painful otherwise it wouldn't be
truth so there is something to be said
for truth in that moment but there's
also something to be said for what is
your mother's state is your mother in a
state of mind where this piece of truth
could just pierce her and destroy her
can you think of a circumstance in which
truth feels good
yeah not to somebody that is
being lied to yes right because it could
jar them like a sleepwalker yeah cause i
was gonna say like truth can feel good
but
if the truth is something like i baked
cookies it's like sure that's just like
a thing you did you know what i mean but
truth we're typically referring to like
snapping someone out of the lies like
telling them about what's going on and
people typically do not react well to it
well my i guess i would re-analyze re
and no i i don't know how to say that
but i guess i would reframe it like this
like you bake cookies and you give them
to somebody
you know it's just like i made these for
you
like i mean that's that's in a sense a
kind of truth sharing you know it's just
like it's it's thoughtfulness
it's it's something outside of truth but
it also is in the same spirit of what i
would call truth if that makes any sense
at all
i'm like you're fat and that dress is
tacky and here we go
give me some
cupcakes i'm hungry
but you know there's time i think i
think good is creation and
evil is destruction but within evil
there is some good and within good there
is some evil of course
what i mean by that is we want to create
more we want more people we want people
to grow and flourish we want to develop
we want to invent we want to explore we
want to expand we want to create complex
systems by bringing energy together and
then organizing it and bad is when
people just destroy it but sometimes you
need to destroy in order to create so if
the ultimate goal is creation there
could be some destruction it's not
inherently evil and if the ultimate goal
is destruction sometimes there's
creation and that creation is evil as
well so for example you're like i want
to destroy everything so i'm going to
make a new method of destroying
everything it's like okay you're doing
bad things and you might be saying i
want to create things but i have to tear
down that machine that's destroying
everything so there is some destruction
right yin yang yeah without no evil
there's no love without love there's no
evil so this touches on something that
jordan peterson analyzes in depth i mean
it's just like too much order is
totalitarianism yeah it's nazi germany
too much chaos is a school shooting
you know and you can't you can't have
too much without being able to balance
it out for some sort of harmony to
emerge freedom too is also an aspect of
love of truth that is also a very
important virtue of that positive
energetic force
you know we we um you know we can't have
too much of super chat yeah smash that
like button
super chat everybody smash that like
button do it for luke luke's not going
to be here tomorrow oh
because he's got a polish mom who's my
polish polish moms come first no matter
what so
uh yeah i wish i was here to what did
you say
the double
trust me trust me trust me i would love
to be here with jack jack i'm so sorry
that you get to miss me uh i will be uh
sad about this opportunity as all my
polish moms come first no matter what
luke all right let's read what we got
what
we got
um polito trujillo says wtf is
timcast.com i don't trust this guy yes
what is this timcast.com you work for
some flyby night
fake news website chris
yeah as often as possible yeah that
makes sense well uh just uh to speak to
my character in terms of uh being the
executive editor we did not change that
one title as you suggested to duh
oh good yeah
[Laughter]
we did have one that earlier today it
was uh though it was like i didn't
criticize over x or whatever and i was
like we shouldn't frame it that way we
should just say biden does acts then we
can mention what the what the reaction
was
right yeah cause you know what'll happen
is like
joe biden he could say a lot of things
and conservatives are going to criticize
him
and then he can say a lot of things and
democrats are going to praise him you
know what i mean so it's like you could
choose how you want to frame it whether
it's positive or negative so i'm like
just we'll just say what it is and then
we'll include commentary in it you know
so we try to do well we revised the
title yeah and then we also put an
editor's note explaining what the
original title was why we changed it and
what happened so everybody is informed
about what's going on there was an
article about uh a
woman who got accused of being racist so
we took it down and someone actually
super chat they're like why would you
take down an article i thought you were
trying to be better it's like yes
because an article went up and we were
like we don't want to do that we don't
want to just make you know articles like
this we want to talk about things that
are actually important whether it's
overtly political or otherwise we like
we have an article like spider-man is
the second big gross highest grossing
movie ever i'm like that's huge it's a
record-breaking cultural moment and
people like the movie and so i think it
matters and then an article about some
lady in a grocery store yelling at a
woman or whatever i'm just like i don't
know if that's like
people need to know about that you know
what i mean right like i guess if they
want to
but i'm more interested in you know how
people's lives are being affected and
stuff
all right kermode bear says blessed
solstice everyone a great time to let go
of bad things in your life and reflect
on and be thankful for all the good this
is the time to set a new course oh oh
yeah it's uh um what is it from the 20th
20th 23rd until the 20 no no the 23rd is
the shortest day isn't it 21st
21st is the shortest day yeah today's
the shortest day yeah that's that's what
i was like oh crap biden's announcing
his major speech on winter solstice the
longest night of the year i was like so
the long night dark night yeah people
calling him
what's it called dark king night king
night king yeah yeah yeah they made the
game of thrones thing the night king
all right dungusfun says hey tim poole i
like your channel on youtube but there
is an ex-military grunt called terence
pop he makes me laugh i like to laugh
not be serious all the time well you
know that's your thing by all means you
can have a good laugh and stuff like
that
thomas self says i was mad at jack and
still think he did wrong but full
context is important the article was
brought up twice that episode be sure to
view both oh
really he was brought up twice and what
happened the first time the first time
he said i he basically said i don't want
to paraphrase him or put words in his
mouth he's basically just like i'm not
going to talk about that and then she
brought it up again because of a super
chat right another a second super chat
said no
explain that article and that's when he
said what he said oh interesting i don't
know i don't want to talk about it
either way it was five minutes later
yeah oh okay wow
daniel maxwell says shout out to my
immune system i know is acting like you
don't exist but i still believe in you
that's right
[Laughter]
awesome ethics says what is your opinion
on joe manchin as a west virginian as an
arizonian kristin cinema has garnered
some respect with her refusal to obey
the establishment and i have committed
to research her more for re-election um
i like i like that manchin stood up to
joe biden i've only been in west
virginia it's been like a year i've been
in west virginia for a year i'm not
gonna pretend uh no it's been a little
bit less than a year
a little bit uh no well
technically yes
but uh i'm not gonna pretend to know
everything about the history and the
politics of west virginia because i've
been here for a year
but i will say i do not believe he'll be
reelected
i mean the things i'm hearing from
people and locals you know out in west
virginia they're just basically like we
don't care he's out he's done
he might uh i'm hearing change his party
affiliation to independent yeah in that
case he might actually win again because
people do like him but they do not like
the democratic party
so he would be in a i don't know if he
probably still caucus with democrats or
whatever like it matters i i kind of
think he's not going to get reelected
though i think west virginia is going to
be like they want to go full maga they
want trump they're not going to vote for
a democrat
but we'll see man tim suiter says la in
new york 10 times worse than australia
majority of australians living normally
with no restrictions or mandates
australia's not as bad as people are
making it sound um i mean my friend in
australia said she feels like she's
living in an open-air prison but maybe
that's just her i guess yeah i don't
know
open-air prison
joshua sanders says red states won't get
to that point no sheriff is going to
show up at someone's house in texas to
take him away or there won't be a
sheriff anymore is um it was iowa's i i
was a red state right
and the sheriff showed up and arrested
that lady because she opened her cafe
and arrested her
yeah so uh i don't know about all that i
guess iowa can go either way though so
yeah swing straight i don't know i did
notice a comment when we posted the
article about all the bills that are in
the new york state legislature somebody
said if somebody comes to put me in a
camp i'm shooting them
yeah
yeah
all right dan ruck says trump got the
vacs and is boosted he is proud of it
yes trump is very proud of the vaccine
he wants all the credit in the world for
it of course he does and i'm seeing
these uh there's there's a clip and then
some democrat person like activist said
they should the democrats should clip
this and run it as an advertisement you
know you're like look trump's on our
side or whatever and i'm like that just
shows me that these people do not
understand trump's base at all
not in the least bit right to think that
they just blindly are like yes trump
okay what do we got here
how do you say carmen smith
says really really good point
tim let's see where this goes so many
conspiracies seem to be coming true i
don't know what that was in reference to
but hey thanks for the super chat
joseph henson we shall all bear witness
to adam's glory may his radiance fill
you as you walk the path excellent good
reference
andrew goodman says i'll be out of a job
by january 10th for refusal to give out
my jab status
i've worked at this warehouse for eight
years any advice
um well i can't give you advice what i
can say what i would do
is i would get a form that says we will
you know i will you know employee hereby
agrees to fully comply with orders
employer hereby hereby assumes all
liability and responsibility for an
irreversible lifelong medical procedure
employer recognizes that requiring an
employee
for for an at-will employment to undergo
a permanent medical procedure affects
their entire life and will assume all
responsibility see what they say to that
see if they sign it because they're
going to be like i can't sign that and
be a lie why not why not don't you think
the vaccine's safe do you know anybody
that's actually tried that
uh
no me neither but i would really love to
know how that could possibly backfire
somebody i actually pulled well i mean
the the employers back i'm not gonna
sign that
and you're fired anyway right i mean
isn't that what they're gonna say yeah
but i think it'll be really interesting
because then the employee gets to turn
it on them well why won't you sign it i
mean the vaccine's safe you're not
concerned about any adverse events are
you so take responsibility you're asking
me to undergo a permanent medical
procedure i'm willing to do it but i
want you to assume responsibility for
the permanent medical procedure yeah you
know like i don't know if i'm allergic
but if it turns out i am yeah i'm doing
it for you for your company isn't that
your responsibility if you demand it
okay sign the form and then when they
say no you can go around time
everybody's an anti-vaxxer he's freaking
out claiming the vaccine's unsafe
and and then you can say you you call
the company antibacterial companies say
the anti-vaccine companies firing people
who uh you know because they're telling
everybody the vaccine's not safe they
don't believe in the vaccine yeah they
don't believe that's the talking point
right there and there's also a lot of
people who are being threatened to be
fired and then never end up getting
fired because there's a labor shortage
and people can't afford to fire people
that's why the mandate uh is so
unpopular with so many people because
it's going to destroy private business
and just think about the interesting
like
just it's an interesting circumstance
for you to say
the employer doesn't believe in the
vaccine
but is demanding people get it that
could potentially i wonder if that could
open open them up for a liability across
the board with all other employees too
because if they're gonna if they're
gonna say privately we don't think it's
safe
but we're mandating it anyway that's an
admission of responsibility or liability
or at least it can be can be uh seen as
such to put it simply if they don't sign
that form
and they say i refuse
and you can ask them do you think the
vaccine is safe they're going to have to
say yes then you say why won't you sign
the form
imagine what that means to them and all
the other employees people need to
understand this when it comes to
employment there are very serious
ramifications with labor laws that's why
hr exists and hr companies exist so that
an employer
an employer could go to an employee and
say i want you to do this task and the
employee says no and they say i'm going
to fire you if you don't do it the
employee then says i'm being harassed
goes to a labor board and says they were
asking me to do unreasonable things it
was harassment i want to sue them and
they might actually get that so an
employer is going to be very very
careful legally about how they say you
are hereby required to undergo a
permanent medical procedure albeit a
small one or a large one
but if they're unwilling to sign a form
saying we acknowledge liability for you
know for this
they're basically saying they don't
believe in it they're then you then have
them saying we will not assume res
liability for this because it may be
unsafe and then you can tell every
single other employee hey just so you
know the company is hereby stated to me
they think the vaccine's not safe and
they want you to get it you should sue
them
i imagine what would happen if all these
people started suing the company like
imagine if your company said we want you
to you know uh
inject bleach
otherwise you're fired you know what i
mean obviously that's that's not what's
happening i'm just saying in a more
extreme example
okay then they're responsible for what
they tell you to do you know what i mean
so i don't know not not advice to you
but that's what i would do
yeah i'd just be like sign this form
youtube
youtube is a person who writes youtube
dislike return add-on is available for
firefox and other browsers do a quick
web search and you'll find it but you
need to understand about the dislike
button is that they're using like an
analysis machine learning to figure out
what the dislikes should be based on
like views and other data they have
available doesn't necessarily mean you
have the actual dislike button
okay
bremen 1973 says it would be cool to see
on your website videos of on historical
myths and claims by the left and
disproving them
i mean maybe the fact-checking site we
do will will absolutely be doing stuff
like that you know so i
i don't think timcast.com is going to
focus on just going after the left in
that way we want you know the website to
just be a good place for stories that we
think are important
daniel ashley says for the testing
package that arrives how do you know
where was manufactured depends on where
the q-tip is supposed to be inserted
[Laughter]
they were doing that in china man yeah
gross they did it to american diplomats
yeah
serves them right
all right
roberto lara says better example joe
manchin he was the dems champion until
they didn't realize he had a spine i
don't know if he has a spine i think
he's just like i'm not going to get
reelected and i'm going to try
desperately to get reelected because he
represents west virginia which is the
second most trump supporting state in
the country trump won by 40 points yeah
what's the first
wyoming wow but west virginia's got i
think
just over twice the population or three
about three times the population of
wyoming so technically you have more
trump supporters in west virginia than
wyoming interesting
nevermoor says tim's bill gates
impressions sound like morty
i don't think so
morty's morty's more like oh geez rick
oh man oh we can't do it and and fauci
is like
i'm not about you
bill gates is like i'm bill gates and we
need microchips so i i guess there's a
bit of a morty yeah maybe
but but it's different you know i'm
actually doing an impersonation of
family guy's impersonation of bill gates
that's actually where it comes from
he's in the car and he talks like this
what's a quarter
that was the joke you know he's like
he's like they pull up to a toll and
he's like anyone got a quarter and he
goes what's a quarter yeah that was
funny
janet partridge says luke has not always
been anti-trump but has also been auntie
alex jones for some time
oh well yeah it's important to criticize
anyone um
there's personal rifts there's also
criticisms that i think we shouldn't all
be immune from i think criticism and
constructive conversations and not just
agreeableness is needed because if we
just agreed with each other to you know
patted each other on the back that's
when you have absolute idiocy um and i
welcome debate you could criticize me i
welcome it i love constructive criticism
i love having a real and honest
conversation and i hope to foster that
through my media organization and i do
that to everyone no matter who it is
all right info warrior says serpent men
cannot utter the phrase um it's just
some weird words i won't say and will be
revealed if they try according to robert
e howard well i'm not going to try to
read that phrase i don't even know what
that means so i'm not going to read it
maybe maybe you can read it luke can you
read that right there on the screen i
can't see that you know there's a glare
in there you're not even going to try
and read it no okay
what about you chris can you read that
can't read it no no no one here is able
to even even try to read it it looks
like numbers from where i'm sitting it
looks like numbers yeah yeah well you
know i wonder
thickness of my glasses lizards
okay jh says i'm most certainly that guy
yeah people were saying that we should
make shirts now especially after ra went
on the young turks or whatever they're
like just make shirts make that guy
shirts yeah you are that guy
[Music]
okay jh says that he is uh they are
extremely attracted to fouchy i'm not
sure if that's a male man or woman but
there you go he's his own
yeah you know whatever cubicle nate says
you've inspired me to get involved in
local politics i'm working with a
candidate to primary and establish a
republican out of congress also getting
involved in local government as my
father before me hey glad to hear it
you uninvited party crashers kudos to
tim cast for broadcasting tonight my
super chats usually go to yah but i
genuinely think this is one of the best
shows on the internet thank you very
much appreciate it thank you awesome why
are they are they out for the holiday or
whatever
you are here elijah and sydney i'm not
sure a lot of people are most people so
it's good to be lazy i know right lazy
they don't have polish mobs yeah
christmas is what saturday yeah yeah and
christmas eve is friday what the heck
and we're and we're still going to work
tomorrow that's right and then we have
thursday but i guess people got to
travel so yeah travel
ian hall says biden just wanted to pull
it donald trade and the old model for
the new but trump did it with wives
that's excusable but a dog that's messed
up
yikes
he does have a past
martin edgar says the biden vax mandate
is reinstated get ready for
mail and supply chain delays i'll be
forced to test weekly burning up my sick
leave and resigning from the post office
after my sick leave is used up
i had to look in because it's hard to
tell if it says mail or mall i'm like
mall supply chains delays
because i mean that that's true too
camilo montoya says luke's bill gates
sounds sounds like mark dice's brian
stelter
but when mark when mark dice
impersonates brian stelter it's just
like a a mockery it's not a real
impersonation yeah he talks like this oh
cnn you know a report on the news it's
like mr elmo mr elmo
what was mr elmo you know that was the
regular elmo the the rat looking red guy
the rat looking red guy
what
on that communist network what is it
called pbs i don't know hbo
he's on hbo now isn't he yeah i don't
know yeah yeah he was tax funded i don't
like him
of course ben phillips is i'm a mail
carrier and most of my bad dog
encounters are untrained shepherds and
pits people try to blame me when their
dog attacks and they get sued train your
dogs absolutely you're liable your dog
hurts somebody you're the one who's
responsible for it and and and again
it's it's so important to raise your dog
right and to take care of him and and
people don't understand how much time
and energy it takes it takes a lot
um or alternative suggestion get a pug
or better yet rescue a pug yes
no training needed but you have to deal
with the snoring lex mccormick says pill
bugs roly-polies are related to shrimp
and we eat those
shrimps so i'd say yeah pill bugs are on
the menu it's a brave new world indeed
pill bugs they swam in the water we call
them rolly pollies that's right because
you'd see them running around and you
just like poke it you know curl into a
little ball and then you like roll it
around oh yeah the last generation it
was really polished
yeah i think it's regional yeah yeah oh
sure yeah sure yeah what do you call uh
uh
what do you call the device
on a wall where you press down and water
comes out to drink
uh
water fountain
they're called in like cape cod bubblers
bubblers yeah that's new what do you uh
uh so
how how do you refer to sugary
carbonated beverages pop yeah pops in
midwest yeah yeah
pop
and that's what we called it in chicago
i have this funny story where i went out
to uh uh it was it was the team manager
for ezekiel clothing and he's a
california dude and it was two guys from
kentucky and me and my friend from
chicago we were hanging out in
california skating and then the kentucky
guy walks in and he's like yo dude can i
get a coke and he goes i don't got any
coke man and he's like yeah you do you
got in the fridge and he's like dude i
don't have any coke in the fridge he's
like you got a bunch man you got the
orange and the grape and he was like
you want to that's not coke dude and
he's like oh i just meant you know like
like an orange coat and he was like bro
are you asking me for an orange soda and
then i walk in there and i'm like hey
can i get one of those pops and he goes
he's like what's wrong with you people
it was really funny i'm a kentuckian and
we never said coke really we said pop
yeah yeah but your weird tucky accent is
pretty solid i don't think that was an
actual kentucky yeah it was i could tell
everything i could testify to the
authenticity it's real and uh when he
was referring to skateboarding saying
flip what yeah they called it coke and
he said where they're from all soda is
coke weird so they'll be like can i get
a coke and they're like yeah what do you
want i'll take orange
you must have been from harlan maybe
yeah pop
soda pop soda pop yeah i ordered a whole
bunch of the jardiner and then we had
jardinara pizza man is amazing
hot peppers carrots cauliflower celery
soaked in spicy and oily and we put it
all over the pizza
so good
soft drink
yeah i never understood soft drink hard
drink again yeah hard drinks have
alcohol soft drinks don't there you go
all right this should be called high
fructose corn syrup drinks wh wh asian
says tim in the metaverse your clothes
and everything you buy will be nfts nfts
are nothing that you can own but bring
their owners happiness great reset no i
think so too interesting i think every
crypto
is the perfect global currency it's the
perfect currency for the metaverse now
nfts you will owe nothing sure but in
the metaverse how do they track digital
ownership of unique goods nfts yeah
because right now i'll tell you this
i've got like you know oh this this uh
this bottle or whatever is my specific
bottle there are many other bottles you
could buy that i just like it but this
one is mine right there are many bottles
like it but this one is mine and so in
the in the universe this would be a
metaverse would be an nft and if you
want to get the you know
very specific bottle it's going to have
to be coded and cryptified
so that's right
waffle sensei says the new perfect
matrix they make is set the 90s they
call it the peak of our civilization the
tva is loki the tva in loki built their
empire around the same time frame and
they call it the perfect they call it
the perfection of form and function
weird stuff oh everybody knows the 90s
was perfect
i think it may be because the people who
make this stuff were like growing up in
the 90s
[Music]
totally so they make shows where they're
like did i do the best
um ar says i'm going to send my poop
back and the test they send me
don't do that
yeah
[Laughter]
i see that
moose code says luke can you please
please please please no a horse and pony
shirt i will buy 10 of them immediately
horse and pony like what's the reference
to because i think you said a horse and
pony show oh yeah yeah yeah and then
there's the exacerbated which people
love exacerbations hearing
i think we got to make those choices
that's still not the best
misinterpretation of that old phrase uh
biden said a word one horse pony yes
he also says exponentially
yeah
and at first they were like he must have
just you know misspoke but no no he says
it all oh like there's a compilation
it's like 10 minutes long of him saying
exponentially wow
exponentially that's not a thing yeah
wow dude learn learn
everybody needs to be learning talking
good you know what i mean
lethal says
we're all uh we're all we're all in the
matrix and zuckerberg is the only n n c
p in the matrix wait what n p c do you
mean to say we are all in the matrix and
zuckerberg is the only npc in the matrix
hanamagi says since kyle's ruling i've
been wanting to know has everyone seen
the similarities between his and the
making a murderer case also google do
you need to take their bar exam
also google do you take their bar exam
in wisconsin local grads don't
interesting
okay mike sullivan any thoughts on bette
midler's remarks about west virginia
yes these the they're they're cr they're
elitists they're they're better than you
and they know it you know they're the
globo gym of politics that's right it's
true
wes uh wesa blow
i'm a dog trainer and what luke said
about training exercise was right on the
money swap alpha with a leader
also what lid said was brilliant
deduction he's a poor leader and that's
pure profound proof right there i think
so dogs know man yeah yep
efren rio says luke thinking of moving
my family to new hampshire from texas
but my wife is worried about the ticks
because of german shepherd and kids how
do you protect against ticks
um
well you know you always got to be
careful there's some areas that have a
lot of them some areas that don't but i
think just being aware of them and
having preventative measures to be able
to grab them when you do get in contact
with them is is one way to deal with
them um i've been to new hampshire a lot
i haven't gotten one tick at all my dogs
haven't gotten one tick at all either so
so far it hasn't been that bad so um i
mean
you shouldn't be afraid to be in nature
um and if you are in nature again just
take the preventative measures wear the
right clothes if you are afraid of it
and uh have those little things that you
could grab ticks out of your body yep
it's that simple that medicine and check
yourself you know check your friends and
family members get organized you know
get a monkey and have the monkey just
you know take care of it possums are
great
all right the engaged few says since
you're new here i'll give you some some
info politics in west virginia is
populist not republican or democrat in
2014 democrats had the governor
legislature and congressional delegation
majority wow
mick chila says not a believer just
curious what your take is
luciferianism highlights truth freedom
of will worshiping the inner self and
one's ultimate potential traditional
dogma is shunned since humans should not
need deities to distinguish right from
wrong
i don't know um
he's talking about lucifer the the angel
that fell from heaven
right now yeah
johnny california says the first matrix
was so good that people had nothing to
complain about so many people rejected
it and blew it up sounds a lot like
capitalism
yeah
they said well i think the point they
made was that
people
needed
strife they needed struggle and without
it their brains did not accept this this
was reality something was wrong
joseph
la liberty says brendan fraser failed
nancy pelosi
lives
okay
good joke but i'm not going to read it
too spicy huh yep
eamon says luke how about a t-shirt with
r a on it that says what if i told you
i'm not that guy by the way tim
interesting show on ra just caught up
got to say he was pretty
passive-aggressive with you and
condescending need to cut his mic no i
don't do that i will say that um
i did a
i recorded before this show with my
sister and we talked about what was
going on in chicago when we were growing
up
so basically
you know his thing is going around is he
has no real argument against anything i
said so the only thing he can say is
that i lied
so if your only argument is that i must
be lying because if what i'm saying is
true it's bad for your politics i
thought it would be very important to
then bring on a family member who
corroborates
more of what i was saying because my
sister's five years older than me and
remembers a lot more than i do and can
talk all about the south side so that'll
be up tomorrow at youtube.com tim
castanews at pm it's 40 minutes where i
talk a lot about this i directly respond
to the young turks but i i think you
know in that segment that uh they did
with ra there were no real political
arguments other than you know like well
there was no political arguments it was
tim's a liar and we laugh at him and
that's basically what they were doing i
guess jenk was trying to get a rise out
of me because he said it several times
but
you know whatever i don't know you're
allowed to laugh at me i don't care it
just seemed all very mean-spirited uh
they also attacked jimmy dore ruthlessly
um and it was just like oh it's like are
you just trying to start drama just for
attention here it was
the reason why i wanted to record
with my sister talking about like hey
this stuff really happened it's because
i think the young turks have a disdain
for working-class people they're
extremely well-off wealthy elites
they're not necessarily fans of the
democrats they're ragging them all the
time but they you know like anna said
she's better than you and she knows it
that embodies a lot of what they are and
so when you look at the young turks
content especially how they responded to
what happened with me and r.a their
whole segment was just mock insult and
deride they derive pleasure from being
mean to people i don't i i don't uh i
don't like just generally being mean so
you know by all means like you can
insult and do whatever you want but i'd
prefer
not to have those things right so when i
was talking to ra i said why wouldn't
you just want to you know approach these
people with compassion and empathy he
said no he wouldn't do it so if you're
of the political faction that wants to
be mean to people and cause pain by
insulting and mocking people well you're
free to do so that's not who we want
when nance when uh um ruth bader
ginsburg died almost in nancy pelosi
when worther ginsburg died i said it
said what did donald trump say he said
sorry to hear it yeah i'd i'd rather be
of the political faction that has
compassion for people that wants to help
the working class that wants to help
regular people you know get by and live
better lives i don't want to be part of
the group of elite wealthy individuals
who mock the poor and insult people and
tell them they're liars when they deal
with struggle when i had people in
ferguson tell me that they had been
chased and their their and one of their
friends had been killed by police i
listened and we filmed it and we said
wow that's crazy to hear because these
people are the ones telling their story
i didn't say you're liars you're lying i
don't believe you grow up
that's life that's insane that's insane
to do to someone who says they're
suffering
so i i just find that fascinating that
there seems to be you know in everything
with different political factions there
is overwhelmingly on the left a large we
hate and we want to be mean the right
absolutely has that as well and many of
the trump the die-hard trump supporters
were mocking and belitting belittling
ruth bader ginsburg so much they hated
her and i'm like i don't have anything
to do with that i think that's just
nasty man
but you're allowed to be angry and
you're allowed to believe what you
believe and you're allowed to say all
that stuff so all right let's just read
one more here we got fred rods he says
lower your expectations matrix
resurrection reviews are really bad
probably one of those multiple viewings
to understand the message
i've i fully expected it to be bad i
don't expect to be good so yeah but my
friends we're gonna we're gonna record
this members only segment and i don't
think we're gonna have one tomorrow
because we have to i have to travel
quite a bit go to chicago um but so
right now go to timcast.com
sign up to become a member and we will
have a members only segment coming up
and this one is gonna be brutal it's not
the kind of stuff that we can have on
youtube so it's going to be on the
website you're not going to want to miss
you might want to miss this one because
it's pretty it's pretty bad so again go
to timcast.com become a member it'll be
on the front page up on the left around
11 or so p.m you can follow the show at
tim cast irl basically everywhere is on
instagram i think it's timcast
underscore irl no i think it's that
timkus irl right i believe so yeah and
you can also follow me at timcast smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel you want to shout out your
socials chris yeah yeah uh chris carr on
twitter chriscar17 that is uh it's uh 17
because people actually have a phobia of
the number 17 and it's called
heptadecophobia so that's why i selected
17 after my name nice interesting
tomorrow i become you i join you in the
comment section i'm excited for the
trolling that's going to be going on
there's super chat uh
i got a lot of things to say
uh but anyway i have my own independent
media organization called we are change
on youtube i made a very interesting
self-help kind of video on
lukeuncensored.com that i thought was
very interesting and thought-provoking
i'm getting a lot of positive responses
for it so hope to see some of you guys
there lukensetzer.com thanks so much for
having me it was always fun and a
pleasure to be as silly and ridiculous
as i am thanks for having me
we appreciate that about luke i will say
that tim has really sold this upcoming
segment on timcast.com it's gonna be
great it's always fun all our bonus
segments are fun you guys may follow me
on twitter at sourpatchlist thanks for
hanging out everybody we will see you
all in the members segment at
timcast.com bye guys
you